foreign
podcast today's guest is Muhammad hijab
and Ali dawa who is just we're waiting
on him but he'll be here he's on the way
uh thanks for coming bro thank you very
much for having me I appreciate it uh
it's funny um I've been recommended a
lot of people to talk to and your name
was right at the very top of the list
um naturally no no truth be told because
um and when I watch your videos I was
like okay I get this because uh I like
your style you just had Jordan Peterson
on uh you ask good questions you talk
about a lot of the same topics as me but
you commented from obviously a different
angle and with everything I've been
through lately uh having someone like
yourself on I really appreciate it man
thank you very much so elephant in the
room yeah how was it for you viewing the
situation and having you are one of the
uh the leaders in the Muslim Community
how did you feel that that went down
well I mean to be honest with you like
um I was uh sent the video where you uh
and Lawrence were speaking and stuff
like that and obviously it was very
distasteful I think you've obviously
come to that realization um not least
because it's just one of those
stereotypes that people have just Muslim
Community have had to learn to live with
for so long and it does have an impact
on their practical lives but also I
think a lot of what the frustration of
Muslim Community is about is that if it
were other communities
the ramifications may have been much
worse so for example we believe that for
instance when it comes to the uh kind of
protected characteristics because in
this country got the equalities act say
for example okay so um one of those is
like religion yeah one of the nine I
think protected uh characteristics that
Muslims sometimes get the short end of
the straw and so for instance if I were
to make a joke about the Jewish
Community for example about the
Holocaust or something like that there
would be almost no guarantee of no
second chance now what I'm saying is
that this opens up a question about the
extent to which freedom of speech should
be operational in society
um I think the UK has its own boundaries
because we've got hate speech laws here
for example in America it's I think a
little bit more wide in in so much as
it's more difficult to to sue someone
for defamation of character or libel
and they take you know the the
constitutional rights I think more if
you want to put it this way
ideologically uh kind of um as an
imperative for themselves
um culturally but still yet I the main
criticism that will probably be put
forward is there's an inconsistency in
the way that certain things are being
operationalized in the United Kingdom so
for example if I would speak about
certain groups that there would be more
of a backlash than other groups as I
just mentioned so I think that's where a
lot of the frustration is is
um I think it's important to have clear
guidelines for example in a country
where you say these are
the limits of freedom of speech if there
are any limits of course that's where
the discussion should be should there be
limits to what extent should there be
limits of freedom of speech and once
you've understood that okay these are
limits of freedom of speech then what
are the consequences of someone uh doing
XYZ or going against this protected all
these people with protected protected
characteristics so I think that's where
the frustration is for example to put it
in a nutshell people will say that if
this was said about these groups of
people uh this person would have been
de-platformed so that kind of thing okay
I mean
there's a lot to unpack there but I
definitely felt some of what you said
even from experiencing it uh you know as
the as the person who said the wrong
thing and
um
it it felt like
I'm gonna try and make sense of it in my
own way and hopefully I don't butcher
this but you know for example sometimes
you've had a really hard day at work and
it's long and you're [__] miserable
and you just wish uh you know I can't be
honest with this the boss said something
to me I'm really fed up and then you go
home and maybe your other half says
something that's almost like the Tipping
Point
um and you lash out at that person and
because they've upset you or hurt you
but but it's not just about that it's
about everything else and kind of what
you've just said is for me on the
receiving end of a lot of the anger that
I've caused I did feel like I feel like
there's a lot more to this there's a lot
of deeper issues here and it and
obviously I've made the mistake and I'm
very sorry for that and I want you to
know that but also
I I can feel that the the Muslim people
who've reached out to me in in a lot of
the sincerity that they have done
they're fed up and they're sick of
feeling like we don't matter it seems
that way or not as much as much as as
you said other people would be protected
or or
um defended no I mean I think the issue
is is bigger than than any personality
for example me or something what I'm
trying to get at here is that say for
example there's two aspects of food and
speech right there's the legalistic
aspect and then you can say there's an
Institutional aspect yeah so there are
the laws there's a freedom of speech act
for example right which allows you to
say certain things so long as it's not
um hate speech incitement to violence or
whatever and then you have major
institutions uh or organizations
companies like YouTube for example which
we're both on yeah who have like
Community guidelines and they say I'm
sure you're aware like if you if you
speak about a minority group or any
particular group and you have hate
speech then you know you get a community
strike for example you see so the point
is you've got two aspects of Freedom
switch one of them is a legalistic one
another one is a you can call it a
company or institutional one or whatever
it is obviously there's one layer of
problem the first layer of problem is
that with the institutional one like for
example YouTube and so on there is no
they're not elected so obviously the
YouTube Elites the whoever's making
decisions on behalf of YouTube are not
elected so there's a democratic aspect
here which is how is it the case that
something as big as YouTube
institutionally who have as much power
to enact freedom of expression of speech
are not elected and they could have more
power and sway than say a government
would so that's the first aspect
secondly the fear is and this is what
I'm saying it's a bigger issue than just
me and you of course is
the fear is if they are unelected and
they are acting arbitrarily in regards
to community guidelines and cancellation
and these kinds of things if they act
arbitrarily for example so as to
de-platform say person X Andrew Tay
whoever it may be completely remove them
from the platform yeah and not do so
with person y okay the question is
um how how are we meant to feel safe on
this platform
because if the if the if the guidelines
are not very clearly identifiable how
are we mental so I can say something one
day about person X or person while
people X or people Y which the YouTube
Elites will will Define as hate speech
and then they can remove me from the
platform
um I I think this is really problematic
because number one they don't have a
mandate they don't have legitimacy from
that perspective Democratic legitimacy
number two even if they did have a
mandate they are not operating on a
consistent basis with all with all
parties well I don't know whether they
are consistent or they're not but
obviously I would assume they're not
because they're run by people and people
are flawed yeah and when you say
obviously they're not elected
obviously it's a company they run it and
and for that reason they won't be
elected uh one thing I do think that
there are differences in and this isn't
me defending myself yeah of course
because there's nothing to defend you
know I'm I was wrong end of story but I
think in some cases
I think the reason they are differences
in how people are dealt with is
previous character intent whether or not
people meant what they said in the way
that it has been uh absorbed because
sometimes
and this isn't again me talking about me
personally I'm talking generally uh what
someone might say
how we interpret that is often dependent
on our previous life experiences so for
example
to use my example if we're going to go
there some people might look at me and
have their own preconceptions and say
well it doesn't matter whether he
intended to hurt us or not what what
matters is is he said it and this is how
it's making me feel
um how do you think
um and this might not be nice for me
here but I think it's important to have
the conversation
how do you think it made just a an
ordinary Muslim feel when uh when the
comment made in the way it was was said
to be honest with you I mean I I think
that obviously it came across people
were angry right because this is the
kind of stereotype that we don't want to
we don't want to be associated with I
mean all the if for example if we look
at on a statistical basis those Muslims
who uh support this kind of terrorism
like there have been polls that have
been done for example pure research have
have done polls and seen how many people
support terrorism so it's negligible
it's always like you know it's a
negligible amount the overwhelming
proportion of Muslims obviously don't
have those views about suicide bombing
about killing about whatever and so to
continually being associated with that
will make people angry but as I say I
think there's a secondary issue and and
I don't want to keep mentioning the
point but the secondary issue is it
makes people upset and resentful and
angry including myself
that and this is not really about you in
a sense not a normal it's about how the
how the system is operating
on the one hand if I if I say certain
things
even if I say certain things about the
state of Israel for example
okay I believe that the save Israel is
operating on an immoral and unethical
basis for example yeah but if I go
further in this and say and talk about
the legitimacy of the state of Israel I
could be accused of anti-Semitism and if
I'm accused of antimicism strongly
enough then I could be de-platformed
just like certain people were
de-platformed recently the point is is
that when people see
that the the system is not being
consistent or there is not consistent
application of cancellation okay if you
want to put it that way or removal or
then people get more Angry so the point
is is I feel that we should we have to
have a stance as to uh the extent to
which we can offend people okay so if if
our stance is another problem with that
though is is who who defines what what
is offensive and not not to each own
individual is kind of based on what you
feel and think and what your life
experiences and unfortunately as you've
rightly pointed out that's up to the
platform that's what I mean it's a
person who runs the platform for example
like um
there have been people like Andrew day
and others I've been de-platformed
normally removed from the platform me as
a Muslim person who speaks on behalf of
Islam or speaks on behalf of the Muslim
Community or speaks about myself or has
Islamic sentiments I'll be honest I'm
anxious that one day someone's going to
come from the Elites in YouTube and say
you know what this guy's gone too far in
terms of anti-normative Ethics he's gone
too far well you've been accused a
little bit of that yeah they haven't
removed me with the with the you had an
issue with uh well you made a comment
about a small amount of people who was
uh were they sick oh Hindu sorry iPad
sorry Hindu uh I'm sure that'll that'll
go down well
um but the point is is I was I was
watching one of your videos about you
who criticized a small violent minority
of Hindu uh people
um what were they called again that you
said hindutva sorry yeah you know I'm
going to butcher a lot of things in this
podcast I'm trying and I I felt it was
interesting watching you in a situation
where you were going whoa I was talking
about these people a minority and a big
group of people and people were
misrepresenting what you said exactly
and
and it could happen to anyone so for
example if you in this podcast you start
speaking badly as I would as well about
Isis or some Al-Qaeda or something like
that you know some organization which is
uh does that the him dut far and the RSS
some of his leaders like the second lead
of the RSS which is connected to this
particular thing praise the Holocaust
and he said we need a new Holocaust you
know so well when I come out against
these people and it's conflated with
anti-hinduism I'm saying you know this
is Auntie hindutva I'm against the
hindutva and they say this is your
attacking Hinduism this is a clear
example of okay so you're maligning me
what's the next step you're going to
de-platform me now and so people will
deliberately misinterpreting you though
yes yes and and that that is also where
consolation can also be used as a weapon
where
look when I look at my what people were
saying about me I felt like they were
the genuine people I'd hurt and and
sincerely
um were being really forthcoming and and
there were people who were non-muslim
who had also hurt and upset who were
disappointed in me but they're also
there are the more the cynical people
out there who who maybe just love to
like
I watched uh have you ever seen Monty
Python's Life for Brian by any chance
right well it's a religious uh comedy
yeah we're pokes fun at the Bible but
they have these stonings where people
turn up for a stoning they don't care
why they're storing the person they're
stoning they just love a stoning and
I've got no doubt in in in
the power you have in your community
that some people would just love to take
you down and when it comes to a bit like
um the stoning situation that I'm
Revenue everyone ends up getting
canceled because all so so I see that
with you I get I get anxious
when I when I see even I'm not sure if
twitch removed you did they I got a
suspension yeah so that actually makes
me a bit anxious because I think to
myself who's making these decisions I'll
be honest with you because if you can
get suspended or canceled or something
on these basis then what we're saying is
a lot more anti-normative if that makes
sense the other thing is that
um for example with the removal key
mentioned this part of Andrew Tate from
the platform is it that that for me was
a red flag it really was a red flag
because there's there's people in the
community like the Muslim Community who
have seen these uh so-called ex-muslims
some anti-uh Muslims who claim to be
ex-muslims right who have burnt the
Quran eaten it spat out and these kinds
of things and uh offended Muslims made
fun of them and they're still on the
platform
so the question is who gets to choose
who's making these decisions and the
arbitrary nature of cancellation this is
I think the one of the biggest problems
of of this I cannot think though that
consolation it a lot of it is is down to
the level of Interest so for example if
I had a hundred thousand subscribers and
I made the same joke that or same
comment that I made rather
people would not care as much I think so
and and I'm sure the guy who you're
referring to who did what you did at the
Quran yeah if he had two million
subscribers good point it would be
different but then that's another point
so yeah I think you're absolutely right
here why do we need to have all those
subscribers this is a good point
difference exactly yeah and this is
another aspect which is not clearly
defined by either Community guidelines
or anything uh resembling uh terms of
use for freedom of speech so otherwise
why is it that this intentional
discrimination against people with more
subscribers and where's the threshold
this is not it's not us your opinion
yeah because you're obviously making
some very good points here about
inconsistencies yes but what I'm more
interested in is your personal opinion
in terms of would you rather it be more
freedom of speech moral and more
allowance for people to say and do
whatever they want or would you rather
more restrictions I'll be honest with
you you know it does
for us as Muslim people right the moment
it becomes restrictive especially when
what we're saying is anti-normative from
from the ethical standpoint when I say
that what I mean is that we're living in
a world which is the dominant ethic is a
liberal one with a small right because
YouTubers left left leaning right I
don't mean left with a liberal with this
big ill I mean with a small l meaning
it's the philosophical liberalism the
idea that you can for example
um the individual is Central you can do
whatever you want so long as you don't
harm anybody else
um almost all Western governments are
liberal every single one of them right
so the United Kingdom France uh Germany
all of them you know United States of
America
so because the dominant ethic is liberal
with a small l
um and what we're saying is a lot of it
is anti-liberal anti-feminist for
example second way feminism is anti
whatever is fill in the blanks if I were
to say to you we want more restrictions
this will be shooting ourselves in the
foot and nor would we want that for
ourselves or other people what we're
saying is whatever policies that you
have
as in legalistic policies or policies of
of use that they should be consistent so
whatever you're applying to me or to you
they should apply to the person that has
one subscriber or the person who has a
million subscribers or the other person
who's a Muslim who's speaking about Jews
or Jews speaking about Muslims there has
to be consistency and I think that if if
YouTube starts doing this kind of
behavior where they're removing people
whether or twitch or whoever else is
going to make people like me and you I'm
sure very anxious about even using the
platform I I hear you and I as as much
as I'm not really familiar with how much
they do Platform people obviously I
don't talk about the guy you mentioned
because I've had enough of that yeah but
at the same time it's a case it's a case
study exam case study but it's a very
specific one that you've that you've
used and it's not really and this is
another guy called snico I think is
being removed okay well I don't know
about that guy but yeah but what I was
if you're a repeat offender with a
massive audience I I see why YouTube
would be going oh a little hot under the
color this might [__] our money up here
let and and that may be some cynical
reasons as to why he was removed
um but with that though bro let's be
completely honest right if that's the
case like in your situation in a sense
like you came out doing an apology and
stuff like that and I think there's many
people in the Muslim Community a very
forgiving very merciful and we don't
consider using enemy of Islam like we
don't consider you as like thank you
very much by the way
honestly they say you've made some jokes
and you've apologized for them there has
to be a level of forgiveness and
forbearance that means a lot so that's
something I would put to the Muslim
Community like we have to be merciful
you know as our Prophet was merciful and
our religion is a merciful religion we
have to be merciful with everyone but
what I'm saying is that we have to also
be consistent
so in a sense he's a repeat offender but
once again the question is yeah what
terms of use I want to know as a user of
YouTube myself what in terms of use did
he violate because if he violated a very
specific time of use and then he
violated three times as as per the
community guidelines and then there was
a a clear process that was followed and
then after that there was a decision to
uh to remove him then I would feel a bit
more comfortable confident in the
process what I'm saying is that
there wasn't that process from I
understand he wasn't even given one
Community uh strike it wasn't it didn't
go from zero to well the reason why that
didn't look yeah I'm very much hands off
with this whole situation now I've uh
but you see you see what I'm coming I've
moved Beyond this silly little beef that
I had with him and I don't care but but
there was a basically a movement from
people who felt that comments were made
were abhorrent and were completely
um against women and other things and I
don't want to I don't want to go to it
no no because I'm not saying that I
believe any of that are a great yeah I
don't want to get involved but but it
for me as we said earlier when the
people demand things on a level that
they did and I can only remember one
Instagram post I had like God knows how
many likes like Millions okay and
millions of people were like this must
end now and uh could just finish this
point because it's important yeah this
is the point and I do I do feel like
YouTube were and other platforms were
were they were they bullied into doing
that I don't know what they but if
there's one thing that I can um
empathize with this guy on yeah last
week is companies bow to pressure they
may not necessarily believe what they
are doing is Right themselves but if it
cost them their bottom line they will do
what they have to to save themselves now
here's the thing it it's I know it's a
private company
there's two issues here and I'll repeat
them right I apologize for having to
repeat it but it's important for me the
first issue is this
freedom of speech is a concept okay who
is who are its upholders so you have
governments as we've said right
governments are upholders from a
legalistic perspective but then you have
institutions as well now YouTube is the
first or the second most ranked website
according to I think it was Elixir
before I'm not sure who does it now
ranking website right it's it probably
has more of 196 countries in the world
it probably has more power to uphold
freedom and speech and expression than
the vast majority of uh governments in
the world okay it has vast power in
being able to uphold through this visual
expression
number one the first issue is for those
who believe in Liberal democracies and
so on they are unelected this is an
issue I mean because they're they're
Elites they have major power but they're
not elected and they have power to enact
a concept which is ideological and which
a state is premised on the second issue
is this is that now when it you say it's
a repeat offender right for example
however the issue is this is that when
there is no clear guidelines let's say
for example there was pressure from the
community it doesn't say in the YouTube
Community guidelines nor does it say in
the Instagram Community guidelines that
if a thousand a million or a hundred
million people come together and sign a
petition okay that said person can be
removed from the platform okay you see
so if they had that in there for example
if that was a clause that they had in
their Community guidelines then fine
then uh whoever's whoever's agreeing to
that was essential to them the only
issue is we're debating something where
you're saying we have no basis on what
he did or how he did it or whatever but
like I'm sure there are people screaming
at the the computer screen are now
watching this saying well he did this
and he did this and he did this and
that's not like this guy was Snow White
and you know what I mean whatever he
whatever he did but the point is if volt
tested it himself you know or very uh
you know famous liberal philosopher he
said that he I'm paraphrasing but he
said that freedom of speech is when you
when you when you allow your even your
the person you hate the most or to say
what they want to say and I do support
that you know as much as me and this guy
are never going to be friends I do
respect the right of freedom of speech
the problem is is
um
YouTube is a company that wants to make
money and that's their goal they go they
don't give a [__] about freedom of
speech they don't give a [__] about what
me and you think they want to make money
no I get that but this is important for
both of us because if people like me and
you who's a lot of their livelihood is
actually based on YouTube like our
livelihood oh I'd prefer it the way
you're saying yes I'd want it to be the
wild west to be honest with you the less
I have to send to myself the more money
I make ever since YouTube started coming
down on swearing and every penny has
changed you know you know things like
that like the minute you drop an F-bomb
it's like my mates are bleeping out
words in their videos and even that is
to me and YouTube allows pornography
right it's pornography it doesn't it
doesn't but um you can log in and watch
pornography on it no you can't actually
and I think that that's what what they
are gradually becoming more and more and
more censored as as the years go by if
you look at it 15 years ago and now it's
completely different and moreover like
you know we're living in um uh well I
live in London right in the city of
London and a lot of these uh this
they're called drill artists yeah it
used to be called Grime back and then
her parents called now now they're
they're literally threatening other
people from the other postcodes I'm
gonna do this and that and sometimes it
actually happens so the point is is once
again it goes back to this arbitrariness
of like inconsistencies but yeah I don't
wanna talk about console culture just
generally though yeah yeah Beyond
YouTube yeah
um
it is a really interesting phenomenon
when you have like to put my video for
example uh however 1.0 million views or
tens of thousands of comments all these
messages
um what is what is your take on that
because I'm sure you've kind of had
people Target you before yeah of course
I have it all the time I'm probably one
of those targeted persons in the UK oh
well that's great
um bro look I'll be honest with you like
I I always like somebody it takes her a
big man to Humble himself right and the
fact that you did that you know is
definitely something I consider it to be
praiseworthy the fact that you're having
this conversation with me now is
praiseworthy I think this is I can't see
how the Muslim Community or any other
community can see this in any other way
as than as a positive thing okay that
you're doing this and you're you're
making an effort as one of the probably
the most vocal persons and maybe one of
the most influential persons in the
United Kingdom to uh to outreach to one
of the biggest communities now in the
United king it was a Muslim Community
wow say is I think that
if someone comes forward and wants to
learn about Islam for example about
Muslim people that will be the the
ultimate kind of test for their for
their genuinity and authenticity in this
regards for example the fact that you're
having me now we're going to speak about
probably Islamic themes and what is
Islam and how do Muslims connect with it
and some of the gender issues that you
know may make us anti-normative to a lot
of people and how do we kind of square
the circle and so on
um these kinds of things where you're
where you're genuinely trying to make an
effort to understand I think that that
goes way further in the Muslim Community
because people say okay this guy's
actually trying to make an effort here
yeah and um you know without feeling
sorry for myself or anything
um some of the things that I've been
accused of me in the last week have been
pretty heartbreaking you know because I
do have close friends who are Muslim
yeah and
um
yeah it's been a it's been eye-opening
man people call me racist people call me
a lot of different things and uh and I
get it if you especially if you don't
know me that clip it looks [__]
terrible
um but I think the more I hope the more
people get to know me who haven't
previously known media we'll see what's
what's in here
um I was wondering specifically when
you're in Islam and you make a mistake
any mistake whether it could be my
mistake or a mistake of an equivalent
what does the Quran teach you as a way
of
making amends and showing that you are
I guess
sorry and you know want to be better
so if if a this this question is we need
to unpack a little bit so I'm sure as
um say for example for non-muslim okay
becomes a Muslim so in a sense we would
consider them to be um on the wrong path
for example if they were non-muslims
maybe not intentionally maybe because of
society whatever maybe but we believe
Islam is a true path and I explain why
that is in a second but
um let's say for example you've got a
non-muslim who becomes a Muslim so we
believe that that individual has a clean
slate now
um and this is uh mentioned the Quran in
chapter 25 of the Quran
except for the ones who uh you know
repent and believe and they do good
works that God will transform all of
their bad deeds into good deeds in fact
so that's one category of people so
converts to Islam are the most honored
in that sense because they have you know
a clean slate so anything they had done
in the past had been completely
eradicated and cleaned up is that no
matter because no matter what they've
done what if I'd like shot a school up
and killed a load of kids yeah even
there wow yeah anything any any
particular thing that you've done the
religion of Islam says whatever your
past is God is merciful and forgiving
and that he will forgive anything that
you have done within Islam the thing
that wipes away your sins is repentance
and repentance is just going back to God
and asking him for forgiveness so we
always believe there's a second chance
there's no individual whose threshold
has been met that critical mass has been
reached that there is no um there's
there is no second chance for them we
believe everyone being a second chance
at the end of your videos you are
beginning our end you talk uh the
charity work that you do yeah and you
talk about if you do this you'll be
looked upon favorably by God and that
sort of thing and it made me wonder like
uh if that is
I don't know a big part of the
psychology that people are yeah signing
up for I think what is is that Islam
fundamentally uh is tawheed which means
pure monotheism to believe there's only
one God worthy of worship okay so we
don't believe as a man as a god I.E in
the Christian Incarnation theories we
reject that we don't believe in the
Trinity that the Father the Son the Holy
Spirit we believe only one God who is
not a man is not a woman is not an
animal is not Material it's none of
those things
um that he's the ultimate creator of the
universe the most knowledgeable the most
uh powerful and so on and that God he is
the only one worthy of worship now you
speak about him and you say hey sorry to
interrupt you but you said he's not a
man yeah is that normal to say hey I'm
not trying to pull you up no no it's
more it's a linguistic convention you
know is that easier to digest for people
I mean you can say uh you can say about
God that is uh uh it I mean it's not
conventional in the translation okay but
if you say um is a thing God the thing
uh for example that's kind of how I
think about it yeah it's a thing it's
just all-powerful thing it's an entity
which is no powerful thing which
um initiated the universe is maintaining
the universe sustains us as without this
thing nothing else would be okay so this
is already of God that if you remove
this is the necessary existence if you
remove this God that nothing else could
uh instantiate in the universe and so on
this is the all-powerful one so we say
that the the purpose of life the purpose
of life is to worship God which means
means to take this thing as the ultimate
Authority
like in terms of legislation in terms of
veneration to take this thing as the
ultimate Authority so in other words to
say there's nothing that goes above and
beyond this authority to accept this if
some if someone accepts this then
um they are actualizing they are
manifesting the ultimate purpose of life
because if I ask what is the purpose of
life to the say British audience
everyone's going to come with a
subjective purpose the purpose of life
is for me it's love to be loved or to
whatever whatever but is there a purpose
of life is there an ultimate purpose of
life through all things which are living
okay only ask some questions yeah yeah
for a start I've always felt like that
uh I'm I would say I'm agnostic but I
believe in a great power that is out
there that created the universe and that
that does like to me just makes perfect
sense to be honest in terms of
um you know the way you describe the the
purpose of life to be uh to worship uh
God
um a lot of what I'm understanding of
the the Muslim religion is is that there
are almost different uh interpretations
of it depending on where you are and who
who raised you and all sorts of things
um has your interpretation as you've
gotten older because I've watched your
channel and I see you've evolved like
people who watch this now they see
someone who's a professional guy but
back in the day I've seen you uh you
remind me of myself sometimes in certain
interviews and it was I really enjoyed
it like me I was but but I can say a
young man who's a bit cocky and a bit
arrogant and edgy and now I'm still all
those things never goes away yeah but
but when I look at you with Jordan
Peterson and you're very much holding
your own you're a very smart man
I see Evolution and I'm wondering if
that evolution in how how you're
thinking is also uh having an impact on
how you're reading the the scriptures
I'll be honest with you like I started
YouTube when I was like 24 or 25 and I'm
31. so that there's age the fact that
I've got a family now I've got three
children stuff like that you know that's
helped me mature as well but also the
fact that people have to realize when
they look at Muslims and this kind of
goes back to perceptions is that they're
not just operating on the basis of
reading their scriptures so I'm an
amalgamation of things I'm like you know
I'm a Londoner someone who's born and
raised in inner city London in secondary
schools and so on where people used to
fight in the um in the classrooms
outside of the classroom so you have to
kind of develop a kind of a defense
mechanism for that so a lot of that will
come out in my Persona just as I would
probably in yours you in a kind of rough
environment you grew up in so so in a
sense people need to be more mature when
they're doing analysis okay is he
speaking now when he's you know doing
this or that thing in on YouTube
industry or you know getting
confrontational is that as a result of
his Islamic Behavior or is that because
he's born and raised in this kind of
environment because he has these kinds
of pathologies because he was bought and
raised by born and Raiser by a single
mother because he you know has this need
for validation this psychological
pathologies uh shout out to the single
mothers by the way yeah true man you
know what I'm gonna say so all of these
things have an impact so for me
personally I feel like I've been trying
to manage my own inauthenticities like
I've been trying to be as and this is a
this is an Islamic practice it's called
or self-accountability
which one of the um the caliphs of Islam
or the second caliph called he said this
he said
hold yourselves to account before you
were held to account in other words
have this self-reflective behavior and
I've been doing more and more of that I
think me and you both know that being on
a social media and on the public sphere
you're going to get held to account
anywhere by the public right you know
what I'm trying to say you have to
justify yourself justify yourself and it
becomes Ad nauseam it comes very
interesting that's what I've really
tried to apply to this whole situation
is just get my face in the camera and go
say what you got to say I'm here to take
it I know I've [__] up and I'm sorry
you know and and growing as a person the
more real you are with yourself the less
other people's words can never hurt you
because if you know every problem you've
got and every mistake you've made you're
not going to have that meltdown when
someone gives you the home truth one day
and I think that when you are like
everything you're saying resonates with
me for me that the biggest thing is
purpose I I mentioned this to John
Pearson I mentioned to you as well it's
like I'm very fascinated with this quote
by nicho he says that if you have a why
almost any how is possible so this
strong sense of purpose like soon though
if I didn't have like for example this
strong meaning and purpose of life like
for example for me I've been believe
that if anything happens to me which is
like someone abuses me someone shouts at
me someone swears at me it's almost like
I believe that this is either reducing
from my sins it is purifying me from a
spiritual perspective it is
strengthening me from a psychological
perspective so you always spin it in a
manner which will have spiritual uh
benefits so it's a kind of optimistic
optimism as a religious optimism and as
if I didn't have that I'd find this very
difficult I want to ask you about that
yeah what imagine right imagine you
you'd never had the Quran yeah right
obviously it's a huge part of your life
and your identity now what do you think
would have became of you I I think I
would have been a very um loose
individual uh womanizer I think I would
have been a violent guy I think uh you
know I would have done some really uh
wild things maybe I would have been in
prison because the thing is did you just
uh do you feel those I don't know let's
say you're 20 25 years old could you
feel those urges and then you've got the
good book on one hand that you're sort
of trying to be lived by but then
there's that in you the wild man f
absolutely and that's why like for
example
um as a man growing up like for example
before I became I got married at the age
of 20. yeah wow yeah I got married at
age 20 years so obviously because as
Muslims we're not allowed to have sexual
intercourse before marriage I got you
know married at the age of 20. and the
way you've just phrased that I have to
interrupt sorry about it yeah the way
you phrased that was if to say
I really needed that yes
I'm being honest yeah I love the honesty
yeah and I think that a lot of I'm sure
a lot of Muslim men will connect with
that but you know any religious person
will understand what I say because yes
you we do have those urges in building
us yes and you don't want to live a life
that is um against uh what you believe
in what was there an element when you
were about to
um tie them up with the misses and get
married that you were
um
you know in the mo look in my world it's
try before you buy right okay you know
what I'm saying there was nothing like
that well but yeah but was there an
element of fear that oh God I hope this
is because this is it for the rest of my
life I've we've never you know uh look
Islam is not Catholicism in the sense
that and in Catholicism in Judaism
there's a very strict laws of divorce
like for example an Orthodox Judaism
it's only the man that can give the
divorce it's called the get you know and
oh yeah I've heard that yeah and
Catholicism I mean some inter most
interpretations nowadays will say that
you know once you've got married that's
it in Islam there is if you become if
you get into a marriage then you can
divorce either either or like a man or
the woman can can uh in the relationship
so I I never felt
um as if I would be stuck forever like
honestly I I don't have that kind of
mentality and I think if we look at the
early days of the companions of the
Prophet because the prophet Muhammad uh
just to give you a bit of context
there's the prophet Muhammad right who
was a seventh century figure we believe
is the ultimate role model okay who
believed that he was given Revelation
and and so on and he was the final
prophet of a long line of profits and
then he and then you have his companions
who are his friends basically who he
taught and so on so we look at the
prophet and we look at the companions
for inspiration and when we look at the
companions for inspiration we we look at
the fact that they've a lot of them got
married many times so marriage was more
laissez-faire than it is in current day
Muslim communities now it's very
difficult to get married and very
difficult to get divorced why do you
think it's changed so much a cultural
cultural reasons and I think a lot of it
is economic ah it's economic here
because people have made a business out
of marriage
flipping right there yeah yeah yeah yeah
so I especially like I'm originally from
Egypt all right most people like most
men get married at age of 30 or 35 or
something like that in Egypt so in the
in the meantime you know the father of
the of the girl will have to kind of
offer you have to get her a house you
have to do this you have to do that so
it becomes almost like it's it's kind of
like a business not not in the sense
that okay he's not selling his daughter
but families are sort of joining in that
sense yeah and that's like two companies
in a way it's kind of yeah it is like
that and so people don't want to get
swindled or whatever it means so now
because and Muslims in the west have
learned to kind of and I think it's more
moving in that direction to just avoid
all the red tape and just do an Islamic
marriage and the Islamic marriage is
usually just you get two witnesses two
witnesses and you and you give a dowry
and then you and the and the family
knows both families knows and there's
consent from the man and the woman and
the marriage is done how much input do
parents have in Muslim marriages in in
the culturally huge it's massive right
like yeah yeah like especially in the
subcontinent and stuff like that I'm
from the Middle East I'm from North
Africa but I mean they still have a
major impact
um or influence or input and stuff like
that but in the subcontinent I think
it's even more than that because of the
reasons I've just mentioned
um but it's certainly something which
requires investigation but certainly
marriage in in those countries is not as
easy as in other countries in in the
west therefore when I got married at the
age of 20 I thought okay this is I've
been holding myself you know you know in
that sense I love the tricky smile you
know I've been I've been I've been
completely abstinent
well in terms of sexual sexually okay
completely I just want to put a yeah not
even the you like man on his own type
deal to be honest with you this is the
first time I've said this and I'll say
it to you save it for me yeah all right
so but I used to get like wet dreams two
three times a week I'm not surprised
yeah and it was just the body's way of
cleansing itself I used to have a diary
of when the wet dream is to come I used
to be quite interested in it because
in fact I kind of it was I kind of miss
it because it was a way that I could
restrict my restrictions always good for
the human psyche I think it's discipline
but I've carried this with me that's one
thing about Muslim people that I've you
know in the last week I've done as much
learning as I can as I've said and uh
discipline in your culture is uh very
respected and and valued and I don't
think that I have a lot of that in that
sense you know there's a lot of
indulgence if I'm being honest with you
and I do respect that about you oh
Victor Frankel says something very
interesting he said um that when man is
lost meaning he will seek pleasure and
so but and once again when you have a
deep sense of I got a reason for doing
this
I mean the Islamic tradition when it
comes to gender relations Is there are
some conservative elements like for
example it's even that you're trying to
avoid look it's in the Bible in the New
Testament in the new system there's a
very powerful statement I wouldn't go as
far as this but it's like you know if uh
your eye will be plucked out or someone
if you look at the person lustfully of
the opposite gender but we we're trying
to avoid lustful objectification of
women okay so when you were going
through all of that obviously you know
as much as you're a spiritual person
you're also in London you're 20 years
old not only are there a lot of pretty
women around but they're pornography and
there's a lot of other stuff that's one
round that's right so were you just
trying to block as much out of that as
possible or yeah
it just became from one extreme to
another
so did you avoid porn yes yes yes yes
that was that was one of the things I
had to avoid but I've been an advert on
one of your videos and it might have
been Ali's uh and Ali is on the way we
promise he will be here about people
struggling with porn addiction in Islam
and things like that and not you know
it's a big thing yeah a big thing in the
Muslim Community really yeah yeah it's a
big thing that wasn't convenient but
it's when I say I've avoided porn I did
so as much as I could but then obviously
be living in the west like people will
be in the classroom showing you things
magazines these kind of things it
doesn't even have to be porn as well
it's like movies it's everywhere I
actually stopped watching movies
completely yeah because I went very far
like the way I did it was that you know
you had um I had social media and it was
like at that particular time obviously
uh Facebook we want social media guys
then like we're doing any um thing but
when a woman would put out some stuff
like you know see our body parts and
thought it would trigger me immediately
oh man you must have been a nightmare
yeah so I had to delete it I cut it from
the root the thing is with with these
kind of things just cut it from the root
so I cut it from the root I personally
believe that that would have been
difficult like because uh just you know
I was a walking hard on if like 15 16
years old yeah you're just going on the
bus to school but going over some speed
bumps and you're like oh but to be
honest with you I started this this
discipline that I had from this uh from
from like for example sexual restriction
let's put it that way
it started to manifest itself in other
parts of my life so for example like I
started doing my a levels and I wasn't
necessarily like the top guy but I
thought to myself if I'm going to be
restricted in this way I'm going to
start putting the same discipline to my
levels right now when I was in school
they predicted like B's and c's for me
but because I started to put the
discipline the hard work the same kind
of things that like you know you have to
pray you have to wake up a certain time
like for us Muslims we have to wake up
in the early morning to pray because
there's one prayer that you have to
disrupt your sleep you have to wake up
you have to wash up you have to pray
it's a spiritual thing I used to go to
the mosque sometimes and so on so when
you when you have that kind of home
business roughly it changes per season
okay but it's like for example in the
summer time or in this country will be
like three o'clock in the morning wow
and now it's like six so it's a good
time now because you can just stay up
after it yeah that's a lie in for you
yeah yeah so so we pray five times a day
so that's one aspect of um you know
discipline spiritual discipline so I
started saying you know I'm gonna do my
illos and I've got A's and my a level
all my guys well all my teachers were
shocked about it and then I started
going to University I'm going to apply
the same principle of discipline started
doing the same thing at University
started doing the same thing in my post
graduates and I just kept doing it dude
if anyone's out there just me you've got
to stop just leave women alone focus on
your studies guys this is the way
forward it is okay I'm not saying leave
Robin Alone by the way the Islamic
tradition in fact there was a there was
a person who came to the prophet
Muhammad and he said that I'm gonna I'm
abstain from women altogether he said
this who he said that whoever abstains
from my way is not from me meaning it's
the way or the prophet to get married
okay it is the way of the Prophet but
when you say when you say get married
you're getting married there's rights
and responsibilities involved there are
boundaries in the relationship there's a
moral guide guidelines there are moral
guidelines so in other words now the
relationship becomes reciprocal there's
boundaries people are involved it's not
just you know he's having sex with a
woman I want to wait until Ali's here
because I've seen some of his opinions
yeah and he is this guy is fascinating
and then we want to bring him in for the
relationship stuff but I do want to uh
go back a little bit in regards to
praying okay
um you prayed before we started the
podcast
what what is where does your mind go and
what kind of things are you if you don't
mind me asking because I know it's a
personal thing but you know what is it
like for you when you're doing that
because I I've seen people meditate
before a podcast but never pray to be
okay so praying the Islamic tradition
says that uh this is something you find
Orthodox Jews do is that you're doing as
well they pray throughout the day and we
believe that we are a continuation from
the Jewish tradition in that sense not
Judaism I.E the the sons of Isaac or
Judah who is one of the sons but it's
it's more so like Abraham Moses all of
these people did it so if you read the
Old Testament you'll find that Moses
fell on his face quote unquote and
prayed you'll find that in the Old
Testament so it's it's not something new
from that perspective the second thing
is the prayer goes in the following way
so we start the prayer okay and we do
this five times a day and we we read a
chapter which is chapter one of the
Quran which is called the opening and it
goes in the following ways it's a very
short it goes oh praise and thanks
belong to God lord of the worlds the
most gracious the most merciful lord of
the day of judgment or the owner of the
day of judgment
you alone we worship you alone will ask
for help guide us to the straight path
the path of those who you have favored
not the path of those who have earned
your anger nor of those who have gone
astray so in this kind of chapter or
this prayer that we say we're asking God
to guide us okay we're asking the
all-powerful the higher Force the
genderless power higher force not man
not woman not no race or anything this
is we're talking about the creator of
the universe asking for guidance for uh
to that we're asking him for help we're
begging God and then we go down to
another position which is the opposition
of the band position and we say
subhanallah or that
glory be to God the most Mighty and when
we go on the floor and prostrate we say
subhanallah so the most noble aspect of
our bodies the face is being
um put on the floor the lowest part of
the ground to to praise the most high so
this is what we're doing five times a
day so we're humbling ourselves to the
the most high we're reminding ourselves
of our placement and the feeling when
you're doing that because when you I
watch a Jordan Peterson and you um said
can I say it in the way I I would
normally say it yeah and it sounded like
quite nice to listen to you know almost
like singing
um what kind of feeling does it give you
when you go through that out of interest
is there a zen-like feeling I'll tell
you what it is the Quran states
that certainly with the with the
remembrance of God do hearts find rest
so if I had to summarize it in one word
it would be Tranquility
like I think a lot of people want to be
happy in like if you ask there's a film
called The Pursuit of Happiness we all
know about right A lot of people just
want to be happy but I actually submit
to you that I don't think happiness is a
good prolonged state to be no it's
unrealistic yeah and not just that like
if you think of it from a dopaminergic
perspective if you have spikes dopamine
spikes then you're gonna have crashes
usually I mean uh Andrew hoberman I'm
not sure if you should have him on a
podcast effect it's a person who speaks
about dopamine and these kind of well
I've been on antidepressants in in the
last couple of years and uh which ones
were you on I was on something called
Sertraline okay yeah yeah
um not good for your sex life yeah yeah
yeah well uh I've heard yeah but I came
off here I mean you know we you know you
you try but the point is is um it made
me realize being a pleasure Seeker being
someone who maybe doesn't have a lot of
self-control and is indulgent that that
lifestyle I was living pre-searchally
and was very crazy like a lot of you
know booze and other things in women and
and just constantly looking for that
Spike and it's not a state of mind you
can stand for a consistent period of
time happiness yeah isn't isn't where
you should be aiming for it's that
neutral but content exactly place and
and that that makes a lot of sense to me
in fact I think Peterson has something
very interesting on this where he talks
about from a psychological perspective
and and this so you can look at it from
a biological or neurotransmitter
perspective like you know dopamine
having these spikes is you're it's going
to be followed by some kind of a crash
usually that happens hoberman spokes
about it speaks about this quite often
but that's from a dopaminergic
perspective or from a neurotransmitter
then you have the psychological aspect
so this this idea of trying to seek
euphoric moments ecstatic moments is not
something either encouraged or
um kind of uh seen as as the ultimate
purpose from the design perspective
and so
one of the great Scholars of Islam his
name is he said that the world is like a
shadow the more you walk towards it the
more walks away from you so in other
words if you try and seek pleasure from
something in and of itself then you're
likely to not get pleasure from it
so from our perspective if you have a
deep sense of purpose and for us the
transcendental purpose is
um not a material purpose but a deeper
sense of spiritual purpose which is to
worship the all high that everything
revolves around that
then you get this state of Tranquility
for example or doing what you call ascar
which are the remembrance remembrance of
God saying things like subhanah Rabbi
Espana whatever maybe subhanallah glory
be to God praise be to God I actually
feel myself getting relaxed I calm down
it calms me down in fact when I don't do
it on a daily basis if I don't read the
Quran or if I don't do these things I
actually feel more frustrated as an
individual I genuinely like this is how
I feel I feel more frustrated as an
individual it's kind of like going to
the gym like I'm sure you know more a
lot about that you know it's the kind of
feeling that you're going to get like
the endorphins when you've finished your
workout
if you remove that from your daily
schedule your weekly schedule imagine
the kind of impact that will have on you
it's kind of like a spiritual workout in
that sense and kind of the way you're
describing it it's almost like the the
if I was going to relate it to YouTube
for example is like
the goal shouldn't be getting the big
views the goals should be enjoying
creating the content and and the work
that goes into it I guess and that's the
thing like for someone like myself well
I have to be honest with myself the
question I keep posing to myself is to
what extent are you doing this for fame
to work soon are you doing this for
money which is less less so but to be
honest for me we all have an ego the
dragon is the fame for me or the dragon
is the recognition the validation I need
that validation and I I would be lying
to myself if I said I'm not doing it at
all that would be a lie all that I would
be saying for example
um I I don't care what people think when
you look at yourself almost in the third
person yeah and it's very hard to do
this obviously but you know you've
obviously became a massive success and
you're interviewing Jordan Peterson and
uh and yourself now as well doing all
right bro but you know and I'm sure you
have your detractors and your real big
supporters and then there's those people
in the middle what is the broad sense of
how people think about you in your
opinion I think it's positive I do think
so when we talk about Traditions Muslim
Community I think it's positive but it's
always it's always going to be the
minorities that we look at like for
example if you get 80 90 likes and great
comments you're not you might not pay
attention to that you might you may pay
attention to the 10 of negative comments
yeah and that's that's a part of the
human psyche it's a neurotic aspect of
the Human Condition this last week is is
is when you have a certain opinion of
yourself and a wave of people coming and
just say you're this you're that you're
that it you're just like am I like yeah
it's brutal to the the ego do you know
who doesn't have that and and this might
sound completely ridiculous but
Psychopaths I'm not sure if you've ever
seen them in interviews have you seen
like when they say I don't care what
people think I actually believe that oh
million percent like what they said they
only care what they think they don't get
like these people and if you're not a
cycle but if you don't have that
psychopathy and I don't think you do or
I do but temperamentally we do care what
people think it's a natural thing
we need to find mechanisms to try and
moderate that so for me my mechanism is
I ask myself one question what do you
actually believe on this matter
what do you actually believe what's your
belief and so the first thing I say to
myself is whatever your belief is do not
compromise on that belief no matter what
whoever says what because the the word
one thing worse than criticism is having
cognitive dissonance
the idea that you have two contradictory
belief systems or you're acting a
certain way and you're saying something
else that internal inconsistency
produces in the long term a worse
psychological outcome so my first
question I ask myself is what do I
actually believe
if what I actually believe is X and I'm
saying it publicly because I believe
that that's the right thing to say and
there's a negative impact then that's
just a byproduct of Truth which is
you're gonna have to and it's quite
frankly it's a byproduct of success
because you're if if you if people are
not criticizing you then you're unlikely
to be a success one one scholar of
islamism
a contemporary scholar I said
if you don't have people who are
resentful of you know that you're a
failure basically
I mean that that yeah I mean you think
even Drake has people who think he's
like a failure he's terrible and he's
you know so like it doesn't matter how
successful you get for example Drake is
an example of ultimate success right now
in music yeah
um you're a very wise man mayor do you
think so yeah I'm just I'm just building
on the shoulders of giants like
everything I'm saying no no it's copied
no I
I but you do it with swag and we
appreciate that and you put your own
your own thing on it and that and I
guess that's that's uh
that's what we're all doing isn't it
like we're trying to learn from people
smarter than us and older than us and
hopefully then we can avoid making those
mistakes as we get we become those men
uh ideally you know I think that's it
and you know there's a beautiful verse
in the Quran uh which says that uh that
God has made us into uh
that he has made us into tribes
um and people so that you may get to
know one another that God has made us
basically into different colors in other
verses different colors some of you are
this color some of you that color so you
can get to know more about the Human
Condition
that the best of you are those who are
most
um god-conscious and and in fact
famously because I was watching
something from Piers Morgan just
yesterday in fact interestingly they
were talking about Winston Churchill
and they were saying you know there was
a woman who came out and she said
something like you know he was a racist
and all these kind of things right and
and Pace Morgan was saying like you know
but he was a racist however who wasn't
at that time
and so I remembered this verse and I
remembered what the prophet said he said
there's no and this is narrated
authentically he said that there is no
virtue over a black man over a white man
or a white man or a black man that the
best of you are those who are most God
conscious so in other words it's a kind
of spiritual meritocracy
the point is that Islam is a very
inclusive religion now you know in terms
of race religion or even sexual
orientation whoever you may be although
we have our stances which means we want
to watch one of your your talks you said
it uh you'd be surprised at how
practical you can apply uh practically
you can also practically or
problematically yeah yeah you can apply
Islam to everyday life and that sort of
one of my uh preconceptions was oh
really like to me that it seemed like
all religion to me by the way it isn't
an Islam thing before people start
getting at me in the modern day be as
honest as you want but the way I live my
life I always thought is religion uh
really made for the current day of
version of May that's gone through
problems that obviously all of these
ancient scriptures they're old and and
I'm I'm on friggin YouTube like you know
how am I going to connect these dots so
I sort of didn't even
think about religion growing up in that
sense because I just didn't think it
would be applicable to me I think that
it's probably more applicable now than
ever because if you think about what's
happening in current Western societies
right I was just looking at some
statistics of divorce in the United
Kingdom it's really like it's
exponentially increased like at a level
which is going to be a divorce lawyer
Now's the Time bro yeah as you can
understand and so they then you have the
family unit like I'll give you an
example we're talking about the purpose
of life and happiness and contentment
and satisfaction
one one of the most
the one of the best studies that's been
done on this is one by Harvard
University which I think is the longest
uh in terms of a longitudinal study the
longest have been done and it explored
the question of what made people more
satisfied and its conclusion with was I
think they had a thousand people and
they tracked them from the 1950 1950s
1940s I'm not sure but up until like you
know maybe 50 years 60 years
and they kept asking questions every
year and so on
and then it was analysis
um layered analysis over the decades and
their conclusion after all these years
was that the number one thing that makes
a person content is human relationships
I you know your relationship to your
mother your relationship to your father
related to your children your
relationship to your cousins your
friends and so on we would add to that
as Muslims your relationship with God
so it's it's actually not the
pleasure-seeking behavior like the best
information that we have now from
Western Academia I've just cited the the
Harvard uh thing but there's also
uh Pew has done interestingly he's done
a study on who are the most uh Happy
People most content people and in fact
they saw that religious people were more
content according to Pew than uh you
know irreligious people it's according
to Pew in America I think so there is
ample evidence to suggests that a let's
call it a traditional life or you have
family where you're you're propagating
your genetics where you have children
where you have good relationships with
your parents where these old-school
values is exactly what the human uh
human beings need today like so this
question of like today in modern society
religions become irrelevant or has
become not practical I'm pragmatic or
whatever you want to put in the blanks I
think in reality
the opposite is true
and I was speaking to one particular
individual called um Nicola Nicholas
wolfinger who's A demographer in America
and I was asking him in what context
um because he's written books about
divorce and stuff like that I said in
what context is uh for example uh our
children most advantaged
and he said of all of the models family
models that are out there today in the
Modern Age the best is a traditional
nuclear family with religious uh input
and it could be any he said it could be
any religion that's what he said I can't
you know put in my slime he said it
could be any religion but there's
regular practice in that religion
because human beings are essentially
anxiety-ridden creatures
and we need predictability we need
comfort we need relationship so I think
religion actually does help human beings
I actually I
in the family unit I completely agree in
that sense I think politically uh I
think some people use it in a negative
way for their own means but I think in
the family unit and and our goal is to
Forest to say that whether or not
religion is the truth or not is is kind
of irrelevant to the point I'm making
it's about having that belief in them
core values about treating each other
well and all the in the roles that they
encourage people to have because it does
feel like and we'll I really want to get
out of this with Alias the there's a
mate in crisis right now in general and
and it's being talked about by
non-religious people now but it does
feel like when you when you look back in
history of the way people used to click
up and get together and families and
settle down there's people are having a
bit of a nightmare in London just just
just finding a mate and and where do we
fit in with each other and who does what
and all of that so and I feel like
gender roles right now are just so in
I'm not even talking about in in Islam
I'm talking about just in London yeah
there's a huge issue where women are
overwhelmingly disappointed in men and
men don't know what the hell uh women
want and where how am I going to be a
man what kind of man do they want me to
be you know because we've lost all
um resemblance of what men used to fit
into and I think I'm an old school guy
so I kind of know where I sit but not
every woman wants that right now and how
do you view that the thing is in Islam
right so we we've got our own kind of
there's a legalistic aspect and then
there's another aspect we should call it
as you know a psychological aspect yeah
um so the legalistic aspect is that the
laws relating to men and women in
certain aspects are not actually the
same so
the general rule is actually equality
because the prophet said
that certainly men are equal to women
well there are certain things in Islam
which a man can do that woman can do
cannot do and vice versa
so that's the first thing so in other
words uh this might be known to many of
your viewers polygamy or polygamy the
fact that a man can marry up to four
women whereas a woman can only marry one
man
um that a man is for example if there
was an Islamic governance or something
like that he would be expected to to
participate in in military Warfare
whereas a woman is not where for example
the man is commissioned to uphold the
family in terms of protection physical
protection as well as
um you know Financial Protection as well
whereas the woman is not uh in that
sense it doesn't mean she doesn't need
to work or she can't work but it just
means that it's an obligation on a man
or husband so the original meaning in in
society today though outside of religion
it's like equality is just equal end of
story isn't it and do you find that
modern Muslim women are struggling with
yes it's not just Muslim women that's I
think it's modern Muslim women modern
Muslim men I think it's a it's an issue
because there's competing uh values here
well it's especially in the west and not
even in the west even in the Middle East
you know the
um I was I'll call that Colonial
discourse to be honest with you like you
know Colonial discourse of okay these
guys must be right because they have the
world hegemonic power but traditionally
there has been a difference in the way
that we've conceived gender relations to
for example the second wave feministic
movement uh we can't I think trying to
put those two things together is
problematic from an Islamic perspective
and there's going to be this kind of
cognitive dissonance that might come
about as a result of it because there
are these things like for example to be
more severe about it
um a man has a managerial hierarchy in
the house like for example his last word
is what actually is actualized not so
when he puts his foot down that's it
that's it that's it so is that what it's
like in your house absolutely but in in
practice you know my wife has a lot of
influence this way in other ways no I I
I imagine I look in in just general
houses that I grew up in in Newcastle it
was like if a woman wants that wall
painted pink which
but what you're saying is the big
serious decisions a man has those yeah I
mean but in practice is another thing
we're talking here in theory because in
practice you know I mean women and men
have a very much women first and
foremost if you have children they're
going to influence the children a lot
more
I mean world farron said this very
interestingly in his book The Myth of
male power
and this is called a part of the
backlash literature that he put forward
against feminists which which a lot of
people like him and James Tooley and
others have actually put forward
uh he said that look if a woman is in a
company and she is now in charge let's
see she's a manager and she's now in
charge of five people and then she
became in charge of eight people
she in most cases in a capitalistic
Society she'll see that as an
enhancement of her powers this is a
promotion of some sorts because now
you're in charge of more people
if if for example a person is the head
of
particularly a seven classroom and then
it becomes the head of year they're in
charge of more people therefore their
powers have increased it's a promotion
of some sorts and so on and so forth but
if a woman has three children and now
has five
do you see it's not seen as an
enhancement of power no I know and it
all depends on how you define power
because I like what he says Warfare he
says that power is your ability to
change your own situation because if a
woman can influence a child and she can
change the situation from that
perspective
as you can do so disproportionately
a higher level than a man can which in
most cases is the case the Islamic
discourse for example would say there
needs to be a calibrating mechanism
because she has influence in spheres
that he will never be able to have
influence in because she's breastfeeding
she's there's a biological Advantage
here and these kind of things so the man
here is given uh some okay let's call it
checking powers or vetoing powers or
something like that so in other aspects
where the whole family is concerned or
what he is concerned uh that he has a
decision-making ability which supersedes
that of the woman so this is a
managerial hierarchy can I ask a
question though about your life
specifically yeah yeah you you said
earlier you're a son of a single mother
yes uh just like me and um I wondered if
if watching your mother do both jobs as
you know she amazes me how they do it
yeah um how that impacted how you viewed
women and therefore now when when you're
in this relationship with your wife do
you think you view it differently to
other Muslim men who had both parents
there or not it's a very complicated
question very interesting question
actually never been on stacked before I
mean I'm pretty good at my job
no I mean that's a very good question
I've not actually thought about that in
the sense that to be honest because it's
impacted me I feel like I feel really
sympathetic towards single mothers like
like really sympathetic towards them and
I have a lot of respect for them and I
feel like in a sense it's not in a
cosmological sense but in another sense
it's unfair the situation they're put in
because you know at the end of the day
and I think this is the problem with the
glorification of divorce because when
women are put in that situation like you
know Society pushes or let's say
friendship groups women's uh friends
will say to them you know get rid of
this guy when he's left then people like
me and you might may be disadvantaged
quite frankly I do think I was this
Advantage I think a lot like I said a
lot of my pathologies that might be
coming out now on the social media is to
do with the lack of a father figure when
I was uh 13 14 years old so I do think
that it puts children at a disadvantage
puts me out put me at a disadvantage
although I had to plow myself you know
just as you did we had to we had to pick
ourselves up and do it but in a sense it
it filled me with a kind of resentment
four or two to towards individuals that
glorify glorify divorce and uh breaking
up families and also
in the beginning towards my own father
I'll be honest with you and then I you
know I had to work upon myself and you
know remove that now I've expunged I
think all of that from my system
um and now it's it's can I ask you one
more question about this you know yeah
because I remember trying to become a
man without a man in the household yeah
and in the the
the emotions you go through and the
wrestling inside that you go through and
you try and you know you're kind of uh
in the dark almost trying to figure this
out you know was there a bit of that for
you as well yeah I mean for me when I
was becoming like I actually became
religious as I was I actually believe I
became religious as a a result of a lack
of a father figure because I started
having identity a crisis who am I what
am I what you know were you born were
you born into the religion yeah I was
but but it wasn't as my mother's issue
she's a practicing Muslim my father he
was very much a liberal you know like in
that sense he wasn't he was religious in
the sense that he's you know he
considered to be Muslim but it's not he
wasn't practicing from the beginning so
I didn't have a big like I could have
been wherever I wanted to be especially
living in London like you know or I
could have been an individual that um
uh you know maybe he was nominally
Muslim but did other things so I still
went through a self-discovery process
when I was younger and to be honest with
you in so doing I started asking myself
these existential questions what is the
purpose of what am I doing I also have
crisis I actually had a crisis early on
I was like what am I doing here how old
do you think you were when this all sort
of played out is it from 14 to 17 wow
they're big years then yeah and it was
painful it was the most painful thing
I've been through a lot of things in my
life honestly I've been through so much
like in terms of I've had pulmonary
embolisms I've had a brain tumor this
that Jesus yeah that was the most
painful thing I've ever been through the
most painful thing I've ever been
through is existential crisis what am I
doing here doubts is Islam true is this
so I had to go for a process where I had
to ask myself what religion was true
what what well system is true I mean
obviously there was a lot of years that
went into that to ask you to sort of
nail this in in an interview like this
is uh you know difficult but was there a
moment where you remember that feeling
in those teenage formative years of
yours where you went this is it this is
this is the the road for me yeah I do
remember like a joke it was there was a
time I went to I'm originally from Egypt
and Alexandria yeah it's my hometown so
I went to Alexandria and it was Ramadan
and it was not a matter of intellectual
proof because I was looking at that I
was looking at what is what are the
intellectual proofs of Islam so I was
thinking because I was exposed to them
like for example there was a figure
called zakira Knight who I used to watch
when I was younger
and he was a master of exhibiting the
intellectual proof what is the proof
Islam is true so he'd bring forward
things like scientific things you know
which uh I mentioned in the Quran which
he would say that could never be known
at that time and he give examples like
you know the big bang and the expansion
universe and this kind of things and
that for me was okay it was good like
how could the author of the Quran know
this the embryological stages of the
development of a human fetus which even
to this day I find quite surprising to
be honest with you like because it's
mentioned exactly how the fetus develops
and then you know you have these people
like Keith Moore and uh Canadian
professors becoming Muslim because they
feel like they this knowledge could not
have been achieved at the time so there
was there was a there was stock
intellectual proof which I was exposed
to as a as a youngster in my formative
years but then for me it was actually a
matter of going back to prostration I
prostrated and I said to God
you know guide me like and it was very
sincere like I wanted the all-powerful
the higher power to guide me to the
straight path
and I feel like something clicked and it
happened in the next couple of weeks
after that moment and it was Ramadan as
well it was a very you know special time
and whatever something clicked and
thereafter there was no I didn't have a
doubt like I was so certain and for me
having certainty about my existence
about the purpose of life about what I'm
doing here about where I'm going where I
came from what created me all these
things
I I say this without a shadow of a doubt
it is the biggest gift I've ever been
given to be removed of my existential
crisis what am I doing here what is the
purpose of it all this almost this
nihilism that I had like thinking what
is it what is this I remember that
feeling well you know what I mean so
having that removed was the best thing
that happened to me
um can we talk a little bit about
Ramadan because yeah I've only been
really uh exposed to it since Lauren
started practicing it with uh his wife
and he explained to me you know some of
the things that he feels but what is it
what does it mean to you to do Ramadan
so Ramadan is basically we believe it's
a Time
says that it's a time where the Quran
was revealed that it's a guidance for
the people and so on so it's first of
all the the main issue with it is that
it was revealed the Quran was revealed
we believe it was revealed then so once
again the story was that a prophet
Muhammad he had a meditative temperament
he used to go to the cave and then that
one special night that the angel read
you know saw him he interacted with the
angel the angel told him read in the
name of your lord who has created human
being from a clot which goes back to the
embryological stages because something
which clings and so on uh Reed who has
taught human being by the pen taught
human being that which he did not know
these were the first verses to ever be
revealed of the Quran that greed in the
name of thy Lord who created human being
from a clot who taught human being from
the pen that which he did not know so
basically from that moment the prophet
Muhammad would be given Revelations over
a span of 23 years so he's 40 years old
at this time up until 63 he'd be given
piecemeal Revelations on a
circumstantial basis and then you'd have
the Quran which would emerge from all of
this
and so the first thing is that we
believe that the Quran was revealed on
that time obviously it's a month of
fasting as well which is one of the
pillars of Islam to fast the entire
month and for me that's it's a it's a
one of the most physically challenging
things I mean you're a big boy that's
what it is because I'm used to eating
like maybe 4 000 calories a day I don't
know what you have maybe this maybe more
about the same right yes so one the
first couple of days is is horrendous am
I right I think you don't have sex in
this period you're not allowed to have
sex when you're fasting right so at
night time when you pray you can have
sex the issue with it is that
um we usually pray quite long prayers at
night and this is if you look at the
life of the Prophet Muhammad
this is what they did the companions are
the prophet they used to pray half of
the night so imagine praying for three
four hours and you're in that position
the whole time they're going up and down
up back in and reading the Quran the
tradition is to to finish the entire
Quran in one month usually that's what
people do in the prayer itself right so
most mosques do that in London for
example that's why you'll see that they
do night prayers for a long time one
hour two hours would you take us to a
mosque absolutely yeah always I might
need your protection that's all the
things
you're my bodyguard
yeah so um like so that's Ramadan you
you go through the the prayers and then
and then you fast so if praise and
fasting if you look at the the life of
the Prophet that's what his like his
life consisted of fasting and are you
thinking of him and what he went through
while you're going through this process
specifically I'm thinking about the
meanings of the Quran okay usually like
I'm I'm trying to at least I'm trying to
think it's obviously tiring and it's
restrictive because you can't eat or
drink by the way and you cannot have sex
or ejaculate I I've seen Lawrence on do
trying to do like shows mouth bone dry
yeah looks like [__] I mean I would
never be able to do this if it wasn't
for religious uh thing as in it it's
that gives you the the energy to get
through it sort of thing yeah I do and
this goes back to like you commentate on
MMA and stuff like I think a lot of the
fighters especially coming out of the
Dagestan region and stuff like that and
I think they have this they have this we
need I so one of my best mates who
trains me uh shout out to Lawrence I
swear you're my boxing coach he he uh
was a team GB boxer and he said to me
once he went I envy religious Fighters
because they go to another place
sometimes that I just can't go to like
yeah because he's like they're in the
ring I'm in the ringing I might die here
they're in the ring like they think God
is protecting them and they're on this
Mission if you think about how Islam
expanded yeah like think about it and
this is something is usually people
criticize it but you think about it from
another perspective
you you had a group of people in the
Arabian Desert who took over the Persian
Empire and took over the Roman Empire
the two biggest Empires almost the world
has ever known how did they do that
because they did not fear death it's as
simple as that in fact who is the best
friend of the Prophet Muhammad he had a
beautiful saying he said that
mode
that
you know this is a very difficult one
translate but basically try and be
nonchalant about death like don't care
about dying or even want to die like in
other words want to die and then life
will present itself to you
you know what that I'm not a religious
guy obviously I've made that very clear
but
the more I felt like that as I've gotten
older my mother died when I was when I
was younger and it definitely gave me a
sense of
um there's somebody there waiting for me
at the end of this so if anything I'll
be reunited with her afterwards so
almost like it in the way I live I live
my life after that became much more
fearless and more then more fulfilling
and that's what living is yeah living is
it like honestly like I'm not at that
stage because now I'm also support by
the Comforts of modern age but if when
when I look back at these particular
figures like where they're literally
they actually to be honest with you they
they want to die you know not not in the
sense that you know I want to kill
myself
no obviously but in the sense that you
know there's a verse in the Quran it
says
that there's two good things I have a
victory or death that's the scene is a
good thing because if you die your Mata
so when you have that mentality bro like
when you have that much but when you
have that mentality that's that is a way
in which you can live a life which to be
honest with you is the most Brave for
potential life like you can take risks
that you would never otherwise take
because you think death is not it's not
the end it's the beginning I've actually
been put I was in trouble for saying
this oh I'm saying to you right now I'll
put on the newspapers they call me that
we love death activists
the reason we're not saying kill
yourself we're saying that don't fear
death we're saying that if someone was
uh being sorry to say sexually assaulted
in the street that we have The Bravery
to stop that we're saying that if you
have a mentality where death is the
beginning your life will change uh
completely like on his head and I'm
reminded by uh what you're saying well I
interviewed Muhammad Ali's grandson uh
in the last year who's a very spiritual
guy uh obviously Muslim uh young man who
started his boxing career we were
talking about is is his grandfather and
uh and there was a there was a quote um
that I brought with that time about Mike
Tyson who he's taught Mike Tyson was
talking about Muhammad Ali and he went
my Muhammad Ali he was Fearless beyond
anything I can ever imagine he he was
willing to die for what it meant for him
and and
um you know you're you're a Combat
Sports Fan have you looked into Muhammad
Ali and everything in his whole journey
yeah yeah because because I mean I'm I'm
not a religious person I'm I'm watching
Muhammad Ali you know really
sacrifice himself for his people and put
himself out there as heavyweight
champion of the world and go do what you
want shoot me take me I I'm not going to
be a tool uh for what you guys want me
to be which is
um uh basically he wanted to stand up
for his people no matter what it cost
him absolutely and this is uh one of the
famous uh Scholars of Islam in the in
the 13th century
he he was being um like the authorities
at the time were saying that we're going
to put you in prison he said if you put
me in prison you're giving me seclusion
like alone time with God if you kill him
you make me a Mata and if you let me
free then I'm going to continue so
there's nothing you can do to me
basically like he's uncountable from
that perspective yeah and it's that
attitude towards life which gives us the
most it's the most empowering attitude
ever I think I think a lot of these
people like Muhammad Ali khabib made of
I think to to maybe a lesser extent more
extent we don't know
um even like these guys I think they do
have that and it's part of their culture
even wrestling is a is a Sumner in the
sense that the prophet like Freestyle
Wrestling was something that was
practiced by the prophet in fact even
books were written Islamic books were
written about like why doing Freestyle
Wrestling was something which is
encouraged from the Islamic perspective
but it was a book written by a guy
called sealty in the ninth centuries
it's called
hastening to wrestling and so basically
this I I do believe that it's made its
way into Combat Sports this mentality
has made its way into Combat Sports
million percent yeah which is why you're
finding these people you know when I
first discovered uh boxing it was Prince
Naseem Hamed who was the Super
he was the McGregor of his day but he
was far more entertaining than McGregor
he was like the entrances and there's
spinning and all this meh like the mom
was magic yeah uh and I think he's he's
kind of been forgotten by modern day
he's probably one of the best boxers a
bridge boxes of all time right but me
unbelievable like
um and I remember at the end of his uh
uh fights saying um you know uh to Allah
and all of that sort of stuff and um
famously it's a Mike Tyson said the same
thing one time yeah yeah and then he
said I want to eat his children
not the most religious things
just leave that Bell next time yeah yeah
um but yeah combat isn't it interesting
how I think men young men were not
feeling powerful anymore we're we're
losing what what it was to be a man back
in the day and then you have this wave
of combat sport of true alpha males who
are also talking about their religion
and and specifically Islam it let's be
real it's there's not a lot of Christian
guys talking about it it is I mean but
to be fair if you look at the UFC
Champions like as an example right most
of the Champions have either been Muslim
or Christian I don't think there's many
hardcore atheist Champions like if you
think about it uh like Pereira by the
way is a Muslim the one who just oh
really yeah he's on his shahada you know
he's a Muslim massive guy yeah and you
know so I I do think there's something
to be said I'm not saying therefore
there's a causation I'm saying there's
something to be said about is it the
case that religious Fighters because
you're seeing from light with
featherweight Fly Away up until
heavyweight every like and ganu is a
Christian
um now Pereira is a Muslim uh you know
isn't it going back is it the discipline
no that helps you kind of you were
talking about discipline earlier if you
guys live that way discipline discipline
if there's anything about khabib that
comes across as you know when that could
be McGregor thing happened yeah I was
sort of blinded by the Razzmatazz of
Conor McGregor and I mean
it's funny that changed uh because you
know you attacked him after isn't it I
did yeah and you know he was beating up
all men in public I can't support this
um and and at the time I was like uh
khabib first language isn't my language
he's not that charismatic and his style
is very much
um suffocate you it's not as dynamic as
McGregor was easy on the eye you know
but as as the years have gone on
you see McGregor's gone down the
pleasure seeking Road khabib still
dresses like you know just a normal guy
yeah he's obviously got the money but
you say that then they just polar
opposite so I guess now I look back at
it and I um I Heard a real nice quote
from Islam who basically said you know
there was a time where something went
wrong we couldn't afford hotels and
khabib just went I'm covering everything
guys he pays for his whole team and you
know when you when he was seeing his dad
pass away what he's now grown into being
is is the father figure of all these uh
Muslim dagestani Fighters yes
uh I guess I'll have to take my heart
off to him and just say fair play to you
are we uh we got my next guest but I've
been there watching a lot of your videos
mate yeah all right okay uh so you're a
secret fan yeah I mean I kind of can be
honest with me don't no I swear to get
in a crowd like you do specifically I'm
like this guy like it takes a lot of
energy to do that and to actually hold
Court the way you do yeah you know it
looks stressful it's very difficult it's
stressful especially when you go to a
freedom of speech crowd and they try to
kill you really yeah have you seen it
Tommy Robinsons well Tommy Robinson here
to me so I thought that would get me a
pass he hates you yeah Oh I thought that
would do me all right in the Muslim
Community yeah perfect uh because
um we he basically wanted to come on my
podcast and I was like absolutely
[__] not and uh when was this back
then a couple of years a few years back
because he was hanging around at the
Logan Paul KSI fights trying to get any
bit of clout he could you know all right
welcome back to True Jordan podcast
extra guest it is Ali dawa uh you were I
mean I just have to take this on real
quick Tommy Robinson rally what was
going on there like what were you
thinking yeah I think the thing is what
was not going on there really yeah
there's a lot going on to be honest I I
treated it uh firstly thanks for having
us here of course I appreciate it I
appreciate you coming yeah thank you so
pleasure to meet yourself your team I
really appreciate and I think it's
important to have communication I think
the lack of communication is what causes
a big a lot of issues which is one of
the communications I tried to have with
Tom Robinson actually all right but he
avoided it for a long time until we
funny old thing finally met uh yeah so
when you say Matt was that uh no let me
help me oh like this is was it more uh
hello yeah well to be honest it was the
surprise uh show up I had to show up in
one of his court cases because I was
kind of pursuing him for quite a long
time
um in a legal way of course okay um yeah
because he was you know harassing a lot
of people spinning a lot of nonsense uh
summer forbid comments and these things
that he was saying come at the come at a
cost it's not just someone saying
something you know it's like my wife
walking down the road with a hijab
um might have a hijab ripped overhead
and innocent I'm going to the most might
get stabbed so these comments have
consequences so that's why I was very
adamant and persistent of uh
persistently trying to find him and I
told him like on social media list me up
let's talk about let's have a debate you
you claim these things let's have a
debate about it and it just avoided it
and avoiding I was thinking what's he
scared of like if you were so adamant
and believe that Islam says you're not
going to kill the infidels wherever you
find them you know if it helps me and
yourself of course me and hijab have
something planned after
yeah so um yeah so the thing is it was
just like okay it's interesting but he
was avoiding it and avoiding and I
thought to myself why is he afraid so
obviously
um after my uh confrontation wasn't
mistaken um he had a freedom of speech
rally so this was open for everybody and
I thought that's interesting I'm sure he
would have no problem having Muslims
there well yeah freedom of speech isn't
it that's what the banner is about and I
knew it was it was a pretense so
obviously I saw it as a social
experiment I thought okay look let's try
this okay I'm gonna get in contact with
Lucy and George uh the team and I said
look can I come and speak as a Muslim
and they're like well of course and I
thought well I admired that I was at
least they're sticking to their word
everything was planned my name was on
there my picture was there
and hijab obviously we was like I think
it was a copy as we got to know each
other and it was working together you
know and he said let me come I said yeah
why not you know because I'm quite it's
nerve-wracking to read the speech in
front of the far right and it's a big
guy that's a good idea it was like it
was it was a good idea yeah it was a
good idea yeah exactly it was a good
idea so he came we went there and the
moment we got there it just started oh
you're not going to speak no you're not
going to speak I'm not going to speak
I'm like I'm speaking of I'm not
speaking and at the end of the day you
are where we are is hostile at least get
us to the back you know where if you
even if you're gonna not allow us to
speak so where they were keeping us was
as if it was intentional like because
it's a hostile crowd you know so and we
would just look uh were you a little
scared well to be honest look
um at the beginning not really towards
the end when it got hostile of course
everybody in that situation is someone
going to pull a knife you know we don't
know so the thing is obviously um I was
a bit I don't know about him he was like
I'm ready to fight I'm ready to die
did you see what happens have you seen
the video I haven't said no I know yes
yeah so they rushed me in it like wow
yeah physically like they will be yeah
yeah yeah but did you have any injuries
afterwards or no no that's how bad they
were that's a big it's a big head to be
fair yeah yeah
you can't and you can't miss it we went
we went to court we went to court yeah
yeah and one of them got convicted wow
yeah
what do you think it was that and
obviously
I can't even imagine what it take to be
in that situation and the pair you've
got balls right it's a fair play yeah
foreign
other than what is going on in their
heads before you meet them was there a
was there a thing that you felt was the
last thing that you said before it all
kicked off do you remember that be
honest what I remember is that we was
there just waiting and then we had
people come in and saying are you this
you that was okay or whatever just I'm
here to give my talk and it was just
that and then what happened was there
was this guy as tall as hijab and I
think I don't know if he was into MMA or
something he was just running his mouth
so hijab obviously is you know he has to
keep things legal you know it's Too
Legit to Quit so anyways he he said to
the guy I'll say look if you if you're
gonna really run your mouth let's have a
legal MMA fight or a charity mate you
know and I said I said that's quite
creative actually so then afterwards
what we realized the same guy made a
phone call when I saw the phone call I
realized the fla the Football Alliance
or something like that they were about
to come so when they came and surrounded
us and they were like some of them would
like nudging me you know so you can see
they were trying something you know and
that's when Lucy came and the police
came and they told us they took us to um
the out of a van so behind this is a van
in front of us are like hundreds
literally like ready to eat like
crocodiles yeah so they're just there
and they're just they're just spewing
their nonsense and I'm like I came here
to talk and I was thinking what happened
to freedom speech I was I was I couldn't
believe it I believe for Tommy Robinson
the best thing he would have done was
let me speak because at least you'll be
like you know what look we started
freedom of speech we despise what he
says you know he was it was this yeah he
said I despise what you say about defend
to death you're right to say it so I was
saying where's the freedom of speech
crime yeah so the C can speak people
from different religions can speak a a
trans transgender can speak whoever a
Muslim oh so that's when I realized I
said this social experiment is showing
me that the issue has got nothing to do
with freedom of speech it's that Muslims
are not allowed to talk me and Muhammad
we had a good chat before you came about
uh his upbringing and how he became the
way he was and I am Keen to get to know
a little bit about that about you
because in my head obviously there's a
lot of nice chill Muslim people out
there who who have the same opinions as
you guys but they sat at home comfy safe
they're not trying to get up and tell me
Robinson's face so what makes you
different why do you feel like it is
your responsibility or why what makes
you confrontational in that way what's
inside you to be honest I try not to be
confrontational uh our message of like
that what that was an invitation for
people to come to Islam it's an
invitation you accept don't even reject
the social up to you so it is our style
is not to be confrontational but when
you're dealing with different kind of
individuals with Tommy Robinson on the
far right like I've had discussion with
the Britain first I've confronted them
um they are not confrontational
there's a list yeah yeah so the thing is
these individuals who are promoting
hatred they need to be confronted
head-on yeah intellectually what makes
you think that that that's your job
though okay good so to me personally
when I was looking at these things
happening in in what was happening with
the far right Etc Muslims being abused
harassed I didn't find any I don't I
don't have this Robin Hood thing kind of
like I'm gonna come I don't have the
Savior complex the thing is I was like I
wish there is someone out there that can
make these people taste their own
medicine and there was no one
necessarily there hijab newly came into
the scene after this happened so I
thought to myself it was really
frustrating one thing I don't like is to
see Injustice I don't give a stunt
towards I hate it so when I saw no one
saying nothing and these guys just got
free I really enraged me so I just
that's when I just slide my uh pursuing
them and just set them let's have a
debate let's have a discussion let's
have a debate let's have a discussion no
no no no no why why
freedom is supposed to come and let's
talk so it was being rejected so after
that happened I had was it on camera or
off camera on social media because I
tried to reach out to them I think I
once I got Tommy romances now if I'm not
mistaken but I genuinely try to you know
get in contact with them you know I even
went near his house not to his house
because I have respect to his family I
went near a house a park in his house
and I took a picture I said look I'm you
know I'm here and the reason I did that
he loved that he loved it a lot actually
you know it was flabbergasted but the
thing is the reason I did that is
because he goes to journalist house
because the journalist house bangs the
door no you did give him a taste of his
own medicine and I I yeah that's why and
I appreciate you obviously you didn't
bang on the door the way he does yeah
um are you got a wife yes okay is she
not worried like about your safety when
you're doing these things well of course
the thing is we don't like doing it like
for example maybe I can mention on
camera myself that we've had their
friends we've had osmo it was called
Osborne Osmond mornings yeah literally
we would certain times I'm not going to
detail we will take certain measures we
were told like we might be stabbed at
somebody's called on a phone box deal
with that well the thing is I'm just
asking because the last week I've had
quite a few I could do was yeah yeah
yeah we need to I'm going to tell you
something I've come around things yeah
so the thing is at the end of the day
you know we're Muslims we believe in God
Almighty so obviously prayer is number
one you know we ask God Almighty to
protect us so we have our morning and
evening
um something that we recite to protect
us this application uh protects us from
because we believe in the Unseen and
magic and all this kind of stuff and we
believe in the so those are the things
that we do
um pertaining to that but obviously you
need to uh the prophet peace you know to
tie your camel meaning that you don't
jump off a 10th floor and be like oh
yeah God will save me it doesn't work
like that you know we have to use our
brain for example I put my seat belt on
the car I don't say oh yeah you know I
have full trust in God it doesn't work
on that you have to have your questions
in place so when we go to certain places
we make sure that if we're regular
somewhere we become irregular like you
know if we're every week going to a
certain specific location uh have maybe
extra brothers and some other measures
as well you know that you you can wear
and I'm not talking about Firearms by
the way okay
one of the things I really enjoy talking
to Muhammad about uh which I also want
to ask you about is yeah uh Muhammad
described when he was a young man and
and how he was feeling unsure about who
he was and what his purpose was yeah and
that's how he he found well he already
you're already religious but obviously
that was what made you uh more certain
of it yeah was there a moment for you
personally that I I wasn't a Muslim so
this is this might be interesting I came
to Islam 10 years ago wow so my dad's
atheist and he has a very strong hate a
passion like he doesn't like Islam do
you have conflict with him for that oh
yeah for the past 10 years when I'm in
Conflict obviously in our religion that
Allah says in the Quran that after you
show your obedience to God Almighty
you're worshiping him to be obedient to
your parents so if these parents can be
Muslim or not Muslim so you have to be
obedient towards them this is something
that sadly is forgotten in our times but
there's times where like I've had the
times where my dad slapped me in my face
he kicked me out the house and I know
that's not good
that
I think it's it's uh when that happened
obviously um I know he doesn't come from
an evil place but he has this perception
of Muslims and Islam and so he's scared
for me so that's why he was he tried
different approaches tried to use
intellectual arguments okay it didn't
work okay but some pressure on didn't
work or maybe just going for a phase let
him be didn't work so and he was like
and I was becoming more and more
religious so he didn't like that so but
now he's better a bit better where is it
now out of interest because this is
fascinating for me okay like what what
what is his acceptance level at now oh
it's interesting like sometimes it's
very interesting because like sometimes
I'll have moments where I'm like oh my
gosh he might accept Islam maybe oh he
might accept I'm like maybe there's a
possibility and then next time he'll
come up with something and I'm like wow
he'll just he'll just insult Islam and
like say some reason how does that make
you feel like because there is that
conflict in terms of yeah you know it's
your religion and your parents you know
your love yes I do but like our love to
our religion is greater and that might
sound strange you bought you know
elevation to a love to our Lord and the
prophet Muhammad peace be upon Him is
greater than our love it should be
greater should I say it's something that
someone can say easily it's not easy
easy said than done but the thing is it
it obviously it breaks you apart to know
that you know your dad you know is
hostile and honestly want the best for
him in this life and in the Hereafter
that we believe in so you have your ups
and downs but my mom's always been there
till like when I used to pray I used to
pray secretly he never knew he found out
after a couple of years that I pray he
actually quote he actually one day he
walked in so my mom's there I've had
Parents walk in our media and stuff
so you know it sounds worse way worse
yeah this is a different one yeah so
this one is like literally and I heard
my dad but I thought to myself you know
what how long am I going to hide it from
him I'm praying that my mom's like get
up get up get up oh and I was thinking
I'm just gonna pray so he comes in and
there's awkward silence and I can
remember
it's I can't explain how awkward it was
and like scary at the same time so he's
there he comes in this awkward silence
then it goes to Mom and goes what's he
doing
and my mom's like and then and he's
speaking to me I'm in prayer he goes
what are you doing and I'm just and I'm
like sweating and I'm I'm just carrying
on praying so he's can you imagine he
gets a chair and he's watching me
so I'm like I don't know is he there is
he not there is he going is he going to
like what's going on so I finished my
prayer and I look at him and I'm
thinking okay
and by the way like sometimes it sounds
like I'm very fine my dad my dad just
wants the best for me he's just any
other father that wants the best he just
has fears so he turns around to me and
goes don't ever pray in my house again
and what like that killed me that
literally it's like somebody I don't
know it really really hurts because he
wasn't accepting you for who you are
yeah and any kid around the world will
understand us exactly and the thing is
it's like what am I doing so wrong like
what is that so that's what and you were
doing heroin exactly exactly yeah you
know if I'm an addict or something
you'll understand but so to it was sad
but at the end of the day he's better
he's much better now more accepting okay
so so one thing that you haven't I mean
that's that's very interesting and I
wonder how many other people are going
through similar things uh but what was
it that sort of Drew you to the religion
was there a person okay so to me
personally my story like for example I
come from a start like before when I
used to live in London I lived in
another most of my life I was involved
in gangs and stuff like just fighting
your typical just like fighting getting
into fights and all that kind of stuff
so then afterwards what happens I used
to get into a lot of trouble here I got
caught walking with the knuckle duster
um so a undercover officer sorry and I
was I was literally playing around with
it so they stopped me they arrested me
and then my dad heard that he said okay
come in he had a business outside of
London he said to come with me I lived
at a place called Grimsby Grimsby yeah
yes I believe it's one of the most
racist towns in London I mean in the UK
bro bro I I used to be called the
p-a-k-i right and I'm I'm Kurdish but
I'm Turkish would you get it my black
friends would be called that and they'll
be like like you know when you came
trying to say so he's getting the fights
happy days but when I moved there my
whole lifestyle changed it changed from
fighting gangs to partying clubbing
girls all that kind of stuff oh wow so
yeah I would live that last night no
girls for you
I guess yeah and I'm not proud of it no
but
the fascinating thing for me is
obviously when I was talking to Muhammad
it was it was his struggle to avoid the
lifestyle in the first place but once
you've tasted it yes to then turn your
back on it it's almost potentially
harder in some regards yes yes so so how
was there a moment where it got really
bad or you know where you felt like you
hit a bit of a rock bottom to be honest
when I was living that lifestyle there
were certain things that started to make
sense to me like I had like this I
always thought I always believed in a
higher power I thought religion or
man-made to control the masses I thought
I've got enough no time for that I don't
believe in that I believe there's some
kind of a Powerhouse that's basically
what I am just so you know it's fine I
was there I was there a long time ago
you know and I always give this example
you know like I I used to stare at my
socks and you might think why socks out
of everything so I used to look at
myself and I'd be like interesting this
has a purpose it just has some kind of a
design and it has a I know so I thought
to myself I'm more complex than this
socks
and I thought to myself how can the
socks have a purpose and I don't have no
purpose
you're making sense because I've just
had a memory yeah there's a guy I know
who's a scientist who he works on um
human blood okay and that's what made
him religious wow which is so strange
yes you're a scientist you're supposed
to be odds with religion and he went
when I looked at blood under a
microscope I seen a design yeah and my
brain was like there's a Creator yes a
boom that was it exactly to me it was um
not blood but myself no but but at the
same exactly exactly yeah so the thing
is when I had that realization I focused
there is a Creator but if that Creator
exists then why did he put me here it's
impossible for me for him to be a
creator that has is purposeless crater
yeah there must be a purpose and I
thought to myself okay there must be a
True Religion out there somewhere one of
these whichever one it is that it must
be because he must have have some kind
of communication what does he want from
me why am I even here where am I even
going what is all this about is that we
give the example if you're in a train
and or a plane whatever you may and
you've got everything you want on that
train but at one moment you're going to
in a second who put me on this plane
where the hell is this plane going it's
all fun and good but where am I going
and why am I here so this question made
me realize well hold on a second that's
when I opened the Bible
um you know I opened the Bible I've read
the Bible a lot I used to um I was in a
relationship which obviously
relationships outside of marriage you
know Haram is uh kind of yeah okay yeah
it's not permissible so um she was half
white half asian so her mama was very
close with her mom I'd celebrate
Christmas with them Easter with them
um you know just typical I used to put
the Christmas tree up you know
um yeah literally I used to read the
Bible and I was just intrigued and I was
reading and I looked into different
religions I spent three and a half years
looking into comparative religion and
what was this in your mind of I'm going
to select one out of these oh well okay
so you created yes I said one of these
has to be from God which one I don't
know but I'm just going to start my
journey but obviously the concept of one
God resonated with me because I was like
multiple girls so who which God did that
God created that God it has to be one
ultimate power it can't be two you know
so uh
yeah just just to explore that with you
yes because you do talk quickly
no it's all good mate I'm you're full of
uh interesting stuff honestly and I'm
sitting thinking here why one and not
two just out of Interest what made you
think that that was all and it does make
sense to me okay but I want to hear what
you think okay so we use the argument
from contingency so this is an argument
I'll try to present to you he will do a
better job and by the way when he told
me he's coming I said to him look you
just go ahead I'll be honest I'll be
honest with you a much better job but
these are experiences people like I
don't have this we don't have the same
experiences exactly exactly the
contingency
of contingency no this is an argument to
prove why there has to be one God and
not too good so this is a contingent
thing so this thing relies on something
else for his own existence right so we
have three kinds of existence correct me
when uh okay because I learned this
about this it's my teacher in this yeah
so basically we have impossible
existence possible existence and
necessary existence impossible existence
is can we have a triangle Circle
we can't do this okay so we were left
with two things possible existence and
necessary existence this is a possible
existence this could be any other way
this could have not existed right so
therefore what we say is that within our
universe for example there are
contingent things these are things that
rely on something else for the Existence
be our planet be it the Sun be the
galaxies and be it our universe so what
we say is exactly even us yeah so what
we see is you cannot have an infinite
regress of dependent things
right we're dependent our plan is
dependent the sun is dependent the
Galaxy dependent the universe dependent
you cannot have an infinite regress of
dependent things you it require we
require a necessary being which we call
God
this year being which is independent and
self-sufficient which gave rise to all
of those am I right and thinking that I
watched you debate this with three uh
yes that's right yes yes yes those guys
yeah
they were they were quite a character
but the point about them that's good so
so that's their existence
and the reason why we would say that
there can't be more than one of them is
there's a very simple thing in the Quran
which which says that
God has not taken a son and that he
doesn't have any other God with him
had that been the case each of those
Gods would have taken what they possess
from the creation and they would have
tried to outstrip one another for power
so I'm put this way let me put in UFC
terms because you're UFC I love that
okay
now let's let's assume there's two gods
and uh defy each other
now there's there's three options either
they draw
or one loses one wins or both of them
lose okay
if we're saying if we assume that God is
the all-powerful the higher power the
all-powerful one meaning that there's no
power greater than that power
if we say that these two gods are
drawing in a fight where where that
diminishes from their power how can a
all-powerful god draw in a fight yeah if
we say one of them loses one of them
wins once again obviously now you have a
Victor and the other one is not actually
a God now okay okay if both of them lose
neither of them are good huh yeah so
this is an exhaustive uh way of thinking
about it if you have one winner and one
loser that winner is the true God if
both of them are drawing if it's a draw
then that diminishes from both of their
power if both of them lose neither of
them are Gods so in other words it's
it's impossible to have more than one
all-powerful existence but if you have
more than one or powerful then it would
suggest uh that there's it would go back
to one of those three examples like the
Vikings uh beliefs wasn't it uh they had
multiple gods um so I'm not sure I don't
know how true that is but you know I
watch Vikings stay on top of God
um one thing that I'm finding
interesting is the fact that you came
into the religion later on in life and
I'm wondering what is it like for people
who walk away from Islam who are let's
say 30 years old and one day decide this
isn't for me anymore how were they
viewed by by the religion to be honest
we get this question asked a lot like to
be honest they're free to like if they
choose to leave they can choose to Islam
is not in need of anybody
um if somebody decides um a certain age
that I don't want to be a Muslim anymore
good on you you know all the best in the
future you know so it's it's not
necessarily like oh like yes you might
get or you can have every like if if you
had somebody I don't know who just said
I don't know
it's human nature some people but you
know yeah and a lot of it is depending
on the country because there's like of
the like we're talking about even sort
of like slam which says 59 Muslim
majority countries have 196 countries
and so each country has its own cultural
climate like if it happens to Pakistan I
think it's different if it happens of
course 100 different what happens
definitely Nigeria or something yeah
well one of my favorite videos I used to
made I call it a favorite I've been you
know I've been doing my research and it
was just a fascinating uh to hear you
guys talking
um you were reacting to Muslim women who
were talking about their experiences
with polygamy oh yeah and the the women
who were were talking were kind of
I kind of fell for them because they
they looked a bit fed up with it and
they looked a bit like they're saying it
ain't the the feeling I want of a man
who wants more than one woman they
clearly that weren't loving it and yeah
if I'm writing I don't want to quote you
because you probably said it the more
articulate way than I would have you
kind of said
that's Islam you know like a little bit
like you know if you if you want to be a
part of this religion this is what we
accept and what it's not necessarily
there to make you feel great all the
time yeah is that right yes I I there is
there's truth in that so um for in the
sense that
look I mean there's a difference between
someone not wanting to do something in
Islamic practice and someone despising
it so from our perspective if someone is
like for instance doesn't want to wake
up in the morning and pray or doesn't
want to protect the community by
fighting the the enemy Intruder to a
country he's all natural things a woman
does most women don't want to be in
polygamy and that's natural that's fine
it's natural and they're not actually if
it's natural then why do you think it's
ended up the way it is with uh Islam the
thing is not everything there's no
logical principle that says that if
someone likes something that thing is
good
so the thing is is that Islam attempts
to solve communities and societies
problems
and so polygamy is one of those ways
which uh we're talking about single
motherhood single motherhood can be it
can be solved at least to some extent or
the surplus of women in the market on
the marriage Market or the sexual
Marketplace can be uh removed in fact if
you even if you think about an economic
perspective think of it this way single
motherhood is not just something which
impacts families and children and uh
communities we know that that's 100 the
case according to almost all the data
it's actually something which impacts uh
people's the economy as well because a
single mother costs the economy so much
money welfare benefits and these kind of
things that you have to she would
otherwise not be being paid because the
father will be putting money in so this
polygamy
I think uh or polygyny because actually
a man to multiple women yeah if we
consider all of the net you can make a
utilitarian argument you can say look
if you look at the pros and cons and add
them all up the family pros and cons the
economic pros and cons of social pros
and cons the community pros and cons
then there's an aggregated or an
accumulative prose over the cons for
example yeah so that's that's the idea
we're making we're not saying that women
shouldn't feel negative jealous don't
want to in fact in our religion if a
woman doesn't want to be in it you can
put it in her contract in a marriage
contract so you're not allowed to do it
unless you can stop it so what I'm
saying is that
all I'm saying here is there is
flexibility but the the the ruling
itself if someone rejects it then they
have to justify why they're rejecting it
because something in the Quran you can
if you're a true Muslim you have to be
faithful to the Quran true and another
thing people miss out is this that they
make it seem as a religion need is
something exclusive to Islam no I'm not
Muslim practically I mean let me open be
open with you is there a moment of time
in your life where you wanted multiple
women in your life
don't turn around
I've
been some wild times on YouTube let's
just leave it at that exactly so the
point I'm seeing is this though it's not
exclusive to Muslims every man we're
talking about men yeah you're anonymous
I'm a Muslim man so the thing is every
man is polygamist by Nature what Islam
does is send protocols to tell you how
to do it in a proper way that you don't
abuse the other wife you know why
because some Muslims do this as well
they have side chicks Mistresses and
girlfriends so Islam says no if you're
gonna do it you do it the right way you
want another woman you honor her you
speak to her father no having I'll get
whatever I want and I Chuck you to
decide no no you marry you honor you
give her a wedding you provide and
protect for her and I believe any woman
in their right mind if they're feminist
they will be properly collisionly all
day every day one thing that you just
said and I'm not disagreeing but I do
think it's fun to explore some of these
please is men are polygenous in in in in
nature by the nature and by that you
mean men just want multiple women 100
that's that's it that's that's not
biology you know and women are
hypergamous by nature and also like you
can you can make an argument
because this equal this equality premise
first of all gone back to the point we
don't believe that men and women are not
equal in value we just believe that
equality and value does not mean
identicality in rules so we believe that
men and women are spiritually equal
there in fact the Quran actually
explicitly mentions that but I've had
I've had conversations like this with
women before where I've tried to say
like look I'm not saying we're not equal
I'm saying we're different and our
jigsaw pieces are bringing different
things to the table yeah I'm I'm the
protector and and you're the nurturer
exactly why I'm old-fashioned like that
I'm an English guy exactly that's
old-fashioned I just look at look at
your muscle mass look at the size of you
imagine if you're with a five foot one
woman are you talking about me or no no
but I'm saying like if you're walking
over on the street if we get a burger
they'll say you go take care of it honey
I'll be right here I think that's a
disparity that's a problem so what I'm
saying is that when you consider all of
the variables let me give you a few
studies right so one of them is by about
my son Cantonese I think it's the
biggest one that's been done uh which is
about the um sexual
urges of men and women or sexual desire
oh yeah I've seen you arguing with
someone about this
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so
interesting now on the basis I I think
there is no uh difference of opinion
here from a biological perspective that
on as a general rule men have more
frequent more sexually uh not comparison
it's much more pushy for a man as a
frequency and the need for it so that's
from a sexual perspective yeah as you
know from a biological perspective men
have 10 times on average the amount of
testosterone a woman has and
testosterone does contribute to drive
and other things as well aggressivity as
well we're better drivers for sure I
mean there was actually a study no there
was a study yeah
um I'm not being controversial here but
there's a study done by a woman called
Maguire
and I actually did this in a level in
psychology and they they what they did
was they got this um these taxi drivers
before they did the knowledge and they
they done an MRI scan on all of the
brains of men and women and there's a
part of the brain called the hippocampus
region and the there was an increased
gray matter in the hippocampus region
for men after more than uh women after
the period of 18 months so you know it's
fascinating because I watched a show
Once about a woman who was going through
um
the change and she was becoming a man
and she started taking testosterone and
she said and I look I'm taking her word
for it but she said in the uh she said
my sense of direction has gone through
the roof my memory of where things are
in driving and places all of a sudden 10
times better well yeah so no but I mean
think of the formula one right and once
again I'm not saying that women are
better than drivers than women I'm
saying that and there are some things
that men can do or have proven in
driving when there is an equality of
opportunity because Formula One is
there's a quality of opportunity doesn't
matter what you are does it can be a man
or woman and you can't but look how many
women
we're smashing so the reason why that's
the case is because there are some
reactive ability uh strength physical
strength the ability to deal with uh
trauma the ability to deal with
emergency situations I feel like you can
make an you can make a biological case a
physiological case psychological case
that men are better than women or men
are better in certain aspects I think
people and
and that's where you guys I think do
trigger some of these feminists who
don't who as much as they want equality
what what you're bringing to the table
is a lot of information as to why we're
not the same of course it's not yes it's
not that we don't mean as much but we're
not the same well we say that the
biggest inequality is to treat unequal
things equally yeah this is what we're
saying no no I said that don't give a
dog
that's why I said yeah
so the thing is all we're just saying is
you know like you're working as a team
and that's what it is you know and they
have different needs and that's the
thing women women are hypocrates by
their nature we accept them how they are
they want a man that's six foot four I
don't know if it exists they'll go on
here you know yeah but that's the thing
when you were arguing with that woman
who um she uh was a feminist but also a
Muslim is that right yes she didn't ask
scratch she has some feministic views
you know yeah well that was the title
yeah it made for a good title yeah it
worked and um you said look
it did make me laugh I've got a bit he
said if you want me to stand in front of
you when we're getting attacked by some
guy with a knife yes then you better
look after me in the bedroom well
exactly you know why because this is
exactly what we're seeing because
remember I said the greatest inequality
is to treat unequal things equally so
the thing is here I'm at my most
vulnerable when it comes down we studies
that show when it comes to intimacy now
as Muslim men we are not allowed to
sleep around meaning that we even told
Allah says in the Quran tell the
believing mental or his gaze meaning if
I go out and I see a woman dressed
inappropriately appropriately I don't
keep sweating in a cup hijab or a bikini
I have to look away so I am protecting
myself from that with the with the gays
yeah so and then afterwards I'm going
out working for my for my family going
out there come on man look at the rent
prices
and then you're going through all of
that you're coming home and by the way
um she doesn't she doesn't want to she
doesn't have to but what I'm saying is
then I will get another wife how about
that so then oh no I don't want that
well then hold on a second oh that's
Freedom of Choice then well well that's
fine but what I'm saying
no no
Dean she was you know what she was
saying she was saying lawyer games to
your wife don't look at her um go
masturbate
um and I was thinking well hold on a
second let's reverse it you're you're on
the road somebody puts a knife out
imagine me saying I choose not to defend
you I don't have to you will be losing
your mind the families will be
protesting in front of my house yeah you
coward so what we're seeing this I think
when I saw that video that what the
response was well the stakes are
different because uh you know the the on
the one hand but they missed the point
the issue is not about Stakes here the
issue is about possibility so let's
let's stick with the the Islamic model
is a complementarity model it's a model
of complementarity there's some things
that men can do that women cannot do and
vice versa and all that men can do
better than women and vice versa right
so the the whole premise is that if we
work against each other it's going to
cause uh problems in community and
society and so on if you work with each
other as a team you know which is
actually another uh reading of the the
Hadith which means that you are twins
men and women are twins where we're
meant to work together and
complementarity with one another then
that brings about the best results so
for example I give this example yeah I
think it's more of an easy one too for
people to understand maybe is um the
example of uh the firefighter is in
America like so they had this kind of
obstacle course I think it was in New
York and because of it was a quality or
opportunity and stuff like that when
women went through the fire of the
obstacle course they didn't complete it
as much and therefore there was a major
skew in the amount of men and women they
are in the fire force yeah so they made
the time longer so that more women will
be selected as participants but the
point is is if someone was in a burning
building okay if someone was in a
burning building and uh now now you've
reduced their time and you've made it
less efficient why should we
manipulate the variables in order to try
and get a better outcome where there's
so-called better outcome like quality of
opportunity uh and and so doing put
children and men women and children
ironically in danger people will die so
we're saying that the efficiency marker
here yeah is not really being attended
to in a proper way and I feel like if we
really took men and women's
um strengths and weaknesses seriously as
a communist Society we'd have better
results you debate you both debated
homosexuality and you've taught to a lot
of gay people in your videos so yeah
like what is that what is Islam say
about that and and how do you guys view
that in the modern day
I think that you know with homosexuality
obviously Islam forbids uh like
homosexuality as a practice not as a not
as a feeling because no one is you can
say someone is not in control of how
they feel in some cases and we accept
that so someone feels in a certain way
then it's forbidden to act upon it like
in a penetrative way if you're a man so
I have sex with another man and so on
now Islam forbids this
uh it doesn't mean that someone
practices it by the way they become an
ex-muslim or that they leave Islam or
they excommunicate they're still within
the folders it's just seen as a major
sin there is obviously no therefore when
you say a major sin or are there a
number of hierarchy of sins okay yeah so
where would that rank hi very high like
one of the schools of Islam it says up
there with murder something wow yeah
it's very well what about manchin on his
wife or vice versa that's a major scene
as well yeah so if a man cheats on his
wife it's a major sin like is that on
the same level yeah yeah 100 man both
there are things that are in Islam that
main people will not consider it like
for example usury like interest getting
a loan from the bank yes you know things
like that are seeing those major sins on
that kind of level as well so there is a
hierarchy that we have going on which
maybe some Outsiders when they look at
it they'll find it a bit strange but
having said that the argument we put
forward about homosexuality is this is
that there's two there's two major like
ethical Pathways in Western ethics yeah
you have something called utilitarianism
and you have something called
deontological ethics utilitarianism was
spearheaded by someone called Jeremy
Bentham and that was taken on board by
John Stuart Mill and it's being kind of
embedded into what is referred to in our
social liberalism yeah and the idea is
really it's the harm principle which is
that you can do whatever you want so
long as you don't have anybody else
and
we're trying to achieve the greatest
good for the greatest number of people
so that's one way of looking at morality
yeah that is the way of John Stuart Mill
and it's pretty much accepted now in
Western Society so when I say the
liberal ethic is dominant in the west
I'm talking about these Notions that you
can do whatever you want so long as you
don't harm anyone else deontological
ethics is spearheaded by someone called
Emmanuel Kant and what he says is that
what he says is basically that there are
some things which will always be
categorically wrong
and uh if you imagine all of society
doing it uh and it leads to some kind of
impossibility that that thing is wrong
so for example he would say lying is
always wrong and there's no
justification even if death resulted as
a result of it lying is always wrong
these are two ways of looking at it now
these are the two ways that moral
philosophers and ethicists in the west
have looked at the I'm saying on both
ways homosexuality as a practice there
is aspersion cast on the morality of it
and I'll explain how
if we say from a deontological
perspective that the things that if they
were conducted by everybody that the
society would not continue or that
there'll be the impossibility in uh in
that sense
I either also refer to as a categorical
imperative that's why Emmanuel Cancer
lying is wrong because if everyone did
it we wouldn't be able to function as
Society so suicide is wrong because if
everyone did it we wouldn't be able to
function to be death then buy the same
token or buy the same logic then
homosexuality would be wrong because if
everyone did it then so that's the on
the ontological route the more the more
popular route which is the utilitarian
route or the if you like the liberal
route now which is the greatest good for
the great stuff so long as you're not
harming anybody else we would say
there's actually a supposing cause first
of all how do you prove that the harm
principle is true as is there a
scientific way that you've come to to
prove that the harm principle is true
secondly
uh if even if we implemented the hum
principle on homosexuality the question
would be
uh could you make an argumentative case
that it actually harms more people by
way of disease or by way of contraction
of this or as we know from the NHS that
homosexual sex is more likely to spread
certain diseases and so on so could you
make a communitarian argument against
homosexual practice we would argue yes
you can and even if you argue on the
basis of families and so on we were
talking about the stability of certain
families
you could I I would postulate and I
would argue that actually all of the
data almost without exception has shown
that homosexual relationships man-man
woman woman
disadvantages the children more than a
nuclear family incent in this in what
sense in the sense of the child is more
likely to be uh to include themselves in
delinquency the educational levels more
uh less thing they're more likely have
psychological pathology and so on so
even on a utilitarian basis
we would say that the traditional family
setup is superior
to
um the homosexual uh Lifestyle on those
two grounds if you're looking at even
from the Western lens we're not even
saying from the Islamic lens because all
we have to say is that God said so but
we're not going down that I'm saying
that if you look at a mutilitarian lens
or from a deontological lens both would
point to the same reality but do you
think you're reverse engineering a
little bit of this and trying to sort of
make it more palatable for
you know when you're getting challenged
on it a sort of thing all I'm doing is
I'm using the ethics which are seen as
the most Superior ethics in the west to
show you that even based on those ethics
that you can make a argumentative case
against the practice of homosexuality
I've got a question then do you guys and
obviously you don't have to out anybody
but do you know any homosexual guys in
Islam yeah actually uh I had a
discussion with one he came to the park
and I was very it was very profound
because he came and said I have these
Tendencies but I don't act on them
um and he actually blew me away I was
like wow like he was like I just use
this to because he was like I know that
obviously I can't get married because in
Islam a man and man's marriage is
marriage invalid so he was like I would
use this time to get close to the God
Almighty and I thought to myself it's an
interesting way to deal with that
because you know Allah says in the Quran
have you seen the one who takes his
desires as his own God this is very
interesting because the thing is he's
not going to have any partner no he's
not a man no he's not so this is what he
said by the way yeah and he said I would
use this opportunity because uh when you
get married as he said to me as a as a
you know your wife you're going to be
dealing with that and you're not going
to have time for God I will be having
all this time for God and I thought to
myself that's interesting because the
whole point we're here is to have a
relationship with God Almighty obviously
we are allowed to get married he's not I
understand that but the fact that he's
the fact that he's sacrificing that
desire for God Almighty that is the sole
purpose we're here about what nuns do
um in that aspect in that aspect yes
they're abstinate completely okay
depends on the Domination by the way
like um like anglicans they don't they
don't do that no more yeah exactly so
the thing is I wonder how many Muslim
people or men rather or
you know what's really interesting yeah
there's just a rewind two you know I
said to go clubbing partying Etc I think
this is where the discussion will be
very interesting here why because I used
to live this lifestyle it didn't bring
me happiness and I believe a lot of
people that live this life
okay all this kind of stuff okay so the
thing is I really wish we could have
like a cut in the edit right now and
just have him like close to it
so the thing is that lifestyle I realize
it does not bring me happiness and it
will never bring happiness because the
way God Almighty has created us is that
Allah says in the Quran you wouldn't you
will only find happiness in his in the
members of God Almighty okay and if you
forget his remembrance you live a
depressed life meaning what you we are
all we all want some kind of a purpose
and then what happens is the way we are
created we have something called the
fitra our innate disposition we are
created as if like imagine somebody
programmed a robot to only find not that
robot can feel anything but with a
specific thing by giving I don't know
argument said giving it a hat just it's
just that's its most happiness when it's
most happy the thing is here is that
anything that I chased I was never happy
anything I used to do bodybuilding I
used to go boxing I used to all this
kind of stuff and there was always you
don't have to take my chair off I don't
want to embarrass you so the thing is
here is that I realized that it doesn't
bring me happiness got a question on my
life based on what you're saying please
so I drink a lot yeah especially in the
last seven days and I smoke weed and you
know and I've certainly uh I've not um
not exactly been the most strict guy
with myself yeah and and it doesn't
bring me happiness necessarily although
in that moment it certainly feels all
right but you know the hungover and
whatever else yeah you guys have
obviously avoided that or at least you
you have for a long time and you have
recently
but you know when life gets a bit too
much and and you know you need advice or
and and sometimes our Consciousness just
needs an escape yes how do you combat
that what do you do we escape the god
that's what we do we we escape the the
thing here is this alcohol
um weed women men opposite gender
nothing is going to make you happy
period
accept because what I'm saying is the
way we are programmed look you we all
eat food okay you're not gonna go and
drink something that's poisonous you're
not going to go and have bad food you
know why because your stomach will
reject it and you will vomit it this is
a physical logo or might support in
place that when you eat something which
is not good for you in your body the
stomach automatically takes it out the
soul is the same way the soul wants the
remembrance of God and I'll come to what
that means when you give it girls like
this is what I used to do okay I have
girlfriends not happy cause not happy
money not happy holidays not happy and I
was thinking what does it want the soul
wants the soul soul food you know
literal food which is what the
remembrance of its Lord that's what is
connected That's Where It's At Home
truly and if you look into the Quran God
Almighty always says that you will
return back to me let me ask you a
question where are you most comfortable
in your life for example
um is this by the way do you live here
yeah you live here okay this is your
house yeah you know that they say sweet
home home sweet home yeah the house is
the place where you're most comfortable
you can walk naked literally it's your
place your space you're gonna do
whatever you
yeah so the thing is he uh at home you
are the most comfortable yeah now God
Almighty for us is our most Comfort is
when we return back to him that is where
that's why when we come to this life and
we're like why do some things go smooth
why is things not perfect because you
are not home you are not home so what
we're seeing is that when you realize
and I came to that realization I thought
to myself I'm chasing this lifestyle and
I used to I always give this example I
used to go clubbing them I used to wear
a specific jumper but I believe that
looks really handsome like I believe
that you know you know yeah
so the thing is I I used to wear
specific clothes work extra hours to
live a certain lifestyle I came to the
realization I thought to myself before I
came to Islam I thought to myself these
are my masters that jumper that I hate
wearing but I wear it because I look
good in it just as a woman who wears
these this much heels even though she's
uncomfortable in her uh her feet he was
a bleeding she still does it why because
I look good in it so I thought to myself
please sorry I interrupt you I watched a
lot of new videos by Kim Kardashian
about the way she presents herself and
how
how misguided she is well she's willing
to eat poo just to look young and I mean
if that's not enslavement what I don't
know what enslavement is so the point
I'm trying to say is this here that we
are bound to be Enslaved the stuff here
and another philosopher I got the
reference here now Google
um man is Born Free but instructions
everywhere is the same guy yeah I just
remember that yeah man is Born Free but
in shackles everywhere exactly did you
choose your name did you choose your
parents did you she's your sister did
you choose the uh did you choose the way
you look no you didn't so nobody can
come and say we're free we are not we
are Shackled somewhere now what does
Allah say in the Quran he says have you
seen the one who has one master and
multiple Masters would you rather be
enslaved to multiple things or one thing
that is deserving of your worship to me
I came to the realization I said hold on
a second if God Almighty exists which I
believe he does and I found it through
is Islam and Islam to be the truth I
would rather be enslaved to him rather
than being enslaved to my jumper to the
opposite gender to the money to living a
lifestyle that is fake and I I found my
true Freedom when I enslaved myself to
the one who created me because I believe
he's deserving of worship and I believe
he created me when I die all your
friends
that you have me and back then yeah best
believe how are they going to cry for it
I bet you they're not gonna cry for one
day they're gonna forget you they're
gonna back by you they're gonna talk ill
of you yeah and I came to a realization
that I have to prove myself to nobody
about God and I I swear to God when I
accepted Islam it's as if a mountain
went off my shoulder you know why
because I didn't care about who thinks
what of me oh what can't you drive
brother drive Toyota Prius yes
oh I'm shy if somebody sees me oh I need
to wear branded I don't care and this is
where true happiness is found this is
what I believe when I talk about the
soul your soul wants the remembrance of
God and what do we do we give alcohol
weed opposite gender whatever it may be
and then the Soul is saying I don't want
it I reject it I reject it I reject it
and with the moment you give it the
correct food it Embraces it and that's
where you find happiness that's why I
realize I know why I'm here I know where
I'm going I know my purpose and I know
where I want to be and if you don't have
it in your life it's it's like the wind
on a windy day you're like a leaf
wherever the wind takes you you just end
up there I kind of feel like we should
just like almost finish it there because
the way we started was kind of Muhammad
saying a very similar thing about how do
you know where you're going and all of
these questions that you have and you've
covered it from a very similar angle
I do want to ask you one final question
and you can answer together uh
individually because it's how I like to
end all my podcasts how would you like
to be remembered
brother
take your time because we can edit this
bit out yeah okay now I want you to
think I actually think about this quite
a lot I'll be honest because there is a
there is a prophetic saying what a
prophet Muhammad said
that all of the the Deeds of human being
is cut except for three things
a child who is a righteous child that
will make supplication for them
a continual charity
a beneficial knowledge that people will
benefit from
now what I want to do before I die is I
want to have something
Left Behind for the people that they
will benefit from it's not about how I
want to be remembered it's about what
I'm going to leave behind will be used
useful there's a beautiful verse in the
Quran yeah it's in chapter 13.
where she goes like the part of the
verse is like this
as for the foam of the sea it just
evaporates where a mermaid and foundness
as for that which benefits the people it
stays on the Earth
like if you think about all the
inventions of humankind
necessity is the mother of all invention
most of the inventions that we're using
now have actually been created or
invented in the war period because you
need to have like a phone you need to
have this you need to have that
so these things because people were just
they were obsessed with creating things
of use I actually heard Kanye West
saying this in a recent interview he was
saying I don't want to be remembered he
was asked the same question he goes I
don't want to be remembered the person
who who done the the the the the the
lamp post was not remembered this one
that wasn't wasn't remembered but what
they have in place is used so for me
it's not necessarily about me being
remembered as much as it is leaving
something of use for people to use
because in my opinion
when I'm dead three things will continue
my progeny we talked about propagating
your genes in your progeny so I want to
teach my children so that they can
continually pray for me and remember me
and so on number two is a continual
charity which means it's not a charity
that ceases so for example a water well
or a school or something like that
something that when I'm dead because the
statue is not what I speak you know what
I'm trying to say people want to be
remembered in the form of a statue or
something like that no it's not she's
not going to speak but a a a a a a a
school is going to produce people who
are going to speak so I want to have
something like that continue or that I
started this up you know what I say and
I continually getting the reward for
that after I'm dead and thirdly and I
would say most importantly
I want to have something that I've left
behind that people will continually use
say reference 100 years 200 years 300
years someone's going to be quite a new
one day Matt
ress yeah myself personally I believe
personally it's um this concept of um
people remembering you um because I'm
not going to remember you and even if
they did I don't want it because the
thing is one thing that I found really
beautiful in Islam was loving for the
sake of Allah now what does this mean I
I couldn't get my mind around it I was
like what does that mean loving for the
sake of God can I not just love someone
because I love them and then I realized
to myself how selfish human beings are
the moment whoever your relationship is
with you there is terms and conditions
you like it or not I like this person
because of the the
because they might offer me something a
benefit of them Etc so like for example
a lot of people when it comes to like
they saw clout chasing Etc he contacted
me and he said true Jordan wants a on a
podcast
and I said to me you know what bro
you're the great you're the guy for the
job go ahead why Islam taught me this
you know why he wasn't oh his podcast oh
I can get more bro like like even today
I came late you know why not that how
could we bother like I wouldn't really
want to meet you but I didn't need to be
on camera I don't need the clout the
thing is the reason I'm saying this is
because when you love someone for the
sake of God what that means is for
example
if I lend hijab let's say five thousand
pounds and I and I'm there for him all
the time one day he turns around and he
spits me spitting my face me and your
dad will do it
so imagine yeah and then you've done all
of that now deep inside I'll be like and
this is what Islam tells you not to do
oh but I did this for him but I did that
for him
I did all of that for the sake of God
even if you come even if you come and
like slap me or whatever it may be you
know what I'll say I will do the same
thing again knowing if you did this
today because I didn't do it for your
pleasure I did it for the pleasure of
God Almighty so what that means is my
reward is with him but the moment you
reduce it to oh but I did that to you
I'll give you that money I don't need
none of that the last seven days of my
life
there are quite a lot of those feelings
are about people around me are feeling a
bit exactly that left down and people
who you want to be there for you yes you
see it who was that you make a great
point there yeah the thing is Allah says
in the Quran we send a smaller Calamity
to divert a bigger Calamity the bigger
Calamity is that we believe there is
Judgment Day there is hellfire there is
heaven and the god that we worship is
not a God that wants to flow people in
this sense yes this this scenario that
I'm yes through is revealing who's
really loyal exactly but is it a
Calamity yes it is but it might be a
Calamity of people who don't have my
back exactly but what does that show you
it shows you again that nobody is there
for you truly except the one who created
you I think you're both coming from the
same place and I really respect that
which is Islam but also being selfish
exactly giving and uh and I think that's
something that we can all collect on
because for me personally while I'm not
a spiritual guy in that sense at least
yet uh mental health is my thing and
that's what my uh what I want to help
and leave behind
um and yeah I really enjoyed this guys
honestly thanks for your time we will be
putting the links to both of these guys
channels in the description below I've
got no doubt especially because some of
the content we've described that's on
your channels they're going to want to
check you guys out so do check them both
out subscribe to them both go and check
them out thanks for watching and we'll
see you on the next podcast cheers
okay well done guys I loved it thank you
very much bro that was such a
fascinating chat honestly